monsieur le ministre un grand plaisir de
vous accueillir je crois que pour cette
sixième audition en commission de la
défense en même pas un an vous avez
présenté hier en conseil des ministres
le projet de loi de programmation
militaire pour la période 2024 2030
comme vous le savez mes chers collègues
c'est toi de programmation militaire
c'est une loi pas comme les autres une
loi exceptionnelle à la fois parce que
notre sécurité collective est en jeu
dans un monde d'ailleurs plus dangereux
exceptionnel également par son montant
413 milliards d'euros exceptionnel
également parce que elle engage la vie
de nos soldats
alors vous le savez monsieur le ministre
la commission de la défense
a été fortement renouvelée en juin
dernier et nous nous sommes préparés à
cette échéance au travers de trois
cycles d'audition un sur le retour
d'expérience de la guerre en Ukraine un
autre sur la dissuasion un que nous
venons de clôturer ce matin avec les
chefs d'état-major des armées allemandes
sur les différents modèles d'armée qui
nous a amenés à prendre du recul sur
l'organisation d'autres pays cinq
missions d'information dont une sur
l'évaluation de la LPM votée en 2018 14
déplacements en France 16 déplacements à
l'étranger et 4 débats publics pour
également associer l'ensemble des forces
vives de la nation il voit mes collègues
qui nous ont accueilli un peu partout en
France à Pau à Brest à Périgueux et
dernièrement à Biscarrosse et chacun de
ces débats publics on
regroupé plusieurs centaines de
personnes et au-delà de ce travail
préparatoire nous ouvrons aujourd'hui un
cycle d'une vingtaine d'auditions pour
préparer l'examen de ce texte et la
Commission à hier soir désignait son
rapporteur en la personne de Jean-Michel
Jacques et une large majorité et charge
Jean-Michel je sais que nous pourrons
compter sur ton application pour mener
ce travail à bien monsieur le ministre
nous sommes donc préparés et organiser
pour être à la hauteur de l'étude de
cette LPM et nous avons désormais hâte
de vous entendre pour que vous puissiez
nous présenter le contenu de cette loi
de programmation militaire monsieur le
ministre vous avez la parole merci
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
rapporteur mesdames messieurs les
députés merci de m'accueillir pour cette
sixième fois et au fond d'ailleurs pour
cette LPM la deuxième fois donc je vais
aussi tenter d'avoir un propos qui vient
compléter utilement ce qui a déjà été
dit précédemment ou venir évidemment
redonner le sens alors par définition
une loi de programme et singulièrement
votre programmation militaire c'est
c'est un grand porte-avion quand même si
j'ose dire avec du normatif du financier
du capacitaire des enjeux RH donc je
vais essayer peut-être si vous m'y
autorisez de donner un peu l'essentiel
et puis surtout de me tenir à la
disposition du Parlement pour répondre
aux questions ce qui permettra
d'approfondir autant que de besoin
différents sujets je pense aussi qu'il
est bon de rappeler quand même que
derrière votre programmation militaire
il y a quand même des choix politiques
il y a beaucoup de choses qui s'imposent
à nous toutes et nous tous ça c'est une
réalité on va y revenir parfois les
contraintes sont réelles en matière
militaire qui d'une matière technique à
certains égards mais enfin c'est aussi
évidemment une succession de choix
politiques qu'il nous faut assumer on y
reviendra mais sur notre modèle
évidemment d'armée sur la relation à
l'exportation d'armes la question de la
diffusion nucléaire nous allions se
militaires qu'elles soient multilatérale
ou bilatérale et également évidemment en
matière de souveraineté et de relation
avec nos industriels j'aimerais juste
peut-être dire précisément et parler du
Parlement en introduction pour peut-être
signifier et dire à la commission que je
vous ai écrit monsieur le Président
ainsi qu'à la présidente brune Pivet
pour dire que j'étais particulièrement
disponible pour envisager dans
l'écriture de la LPM les dispositions et
dispositifs nécessaires pour associer au
mieux le Parlement pendant la conduite
de LPM ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire
qu'il y a quelque chose qui existe dans
le texte vous l'avez vu qui s'inspire
beaucoup de ce que vous aviez vous-même
introduit lors de la législature
précédente et que je trouve que au
regard des la situation géopolitique
l'Ukraine qui fait quand même que les
choses vont très vite les sujets qui
sont bien l'inflation qui sont qui sont
centraux ils comptent quand même
beaucoup les sujets évidemment qui
tiennent aussi aux différentes
préoccupations opérationnelles que l'on
peut avoir je pense en fait qu'on ne
peut plus voter une loi de programme
complètement figée sur sur cinq années
alors vous me direz de toute façon ce
sont les lois de finances annuelles
budgétaires qui sont les seuls qui
comptent réellement pour ouvrir les
autorisations d'engagement les crédits
de paiement mais je pense au fond qu'on
ne peut pas faire voter nos
programmation militaire et se dire
rendez-vous ensuite en 2030 avec en plus
des échéances électorales au milieu donc
évidemment l'idée c'est de faire une
grande revoyure avant l'élection
présidentielle de 2027 ça me semble
évidemment au sein démocratiquement mais
je pense au fond qu'il nous faut
imaginer peut-être des choses des
remises à jour rapides manuel en amont
des lois de finances et donc sur la
manière de social Parlement évidemment
je serai à votre disposition pour écrire
au mieux dans la loi ce qu'il vous
convient et peut-être aussi dans une
approche bicaméral avec les
parlementaires qui siègent au Sénat sur
la méthode de construction de la LPM sur
la forme bon je tiens vraiment à
remercier quand même l'ensemble des
états majors parce que ça a été un
travail intense donc qu'on puisse dire
et surtout plein d'humidité être capable
de se dire en vérité avec nous-mêmes ce
que nous sommes capables de bien faire
et là où nous sommes parfois plus
fragiles demandent un travail sur
soi-même pour nous officiers généraux
pour nous officiers supérieurs dans la
relation aussi à la troupe qui n'est pas
un travail si évident que cela et au
fond un ciné dit parce que jadis pour
mettre un peu renseigné en tout cas sur
des périodes qui tiennent au 20
dernières années en général on allait
chercher une courbe et là souvent la
baisse parfois un peu à la hausse et
puis si en fonction de la courbe qu'on
demandait aux armées d'essayer de de
tenir un format d'armée bon
là on a fait un exercice différent qui
nous amène au 413 milliards d'ailleurs
parce que je pense que si on avait pas
fait comme ça on sera à moins pour être
complètement transparent et direct avec
vous c'est en se disant au fond si on
fait un examen clinique et donc au fond
à ces techniques parce que une fois de
plus on peut pas mépriser le fond bah
qu'est-ce qu'on sait faire qu'est-ce
qu'on sait moins faire pour aujourd'hui
mais aussi pour l'avenir je reviendrai
parce que je terminerai d'ailleurs mon
propos par ça ne pas se tromper sur les
échelles de temps pour cette LPM merci
au parlementaire qui sont mobilisés dans
les différents groupes de travail et
aussi à travers la contribution des
nombreux rapports on entend souvent dire
mais les rapports parlementaires à quoi
servent-ils moi j'avais donné
l'instruction à l'ensemble des équipes
qui ont tenu le stylo c'est pas
programmation militaire de ne pas
réinventer la poudre si je puis dire et
de regarder l'ensemble des rapports
sénatoriaux et de l'Assemblée nationale
en disant il y a des choses déjà sur
étagère qui existent et donc autant s'en
inspirer et je serais vous faire la
démonstration au fur et à mesure que
nous avancerons dans la discussion de
cette loi que de manière incrémentale on
a intégré l'ensemble des contributions
du Parlement
là où évidemment nous étions d'accord
avec elle ou en tout cas elles étaient
évidemment convergentes avec notre notre
point de vue mais ensuite il vient vous
y retrouverez vos petits aussi par votre
droit d'amendement le cas échéant
j'ajouterai également que j'ai regardé
beaucoup les programmes électoraux des
candidats à l'élection présidentielle ça
fait jamais de mal dans une démocratie
ce qui permet aussi de voir qu'il y
avait des points de grands clivage et de
grandes divergences je n'y reviendrai
pas ou peut-être un peu quand même
et il y a quand même des points de
convergence et je pense dans l'honnêteté
des travaux de cette commission qui ne
peut-être pas une commission quand même
parlementaire comme les autres au regard
du sujet qui nous réunissent et à la
défense de la nation il y a des points
de convergence dans tous les programmes
de Madame Le Pen et Monsieur Mélenchon
en passant évidemment par Monsieur
Macron madame Pécresse et d'autres
pardon pas tous les citer je m'en excuse
en tout cas il y a quand même des points
où évidemment ça converge tout
simplement parce que si on a travaillé
convenablement on a globalement écouté
plus ou moins les mêmes experts en tout
cas s'ils sont pas les mêmes experts des
gens qui cultivent une expertise
convergente on y retrouve quand même ce
commun et c'est quand même plutôt
heureux et après il y aura peut-être
quelques divergences nourris peut-être
aussi du climat ambiant mais ça nous
allons l'occasion aussi d'y revenir sur
le fond j'aimerais poursuivre mon propos
en disant aussi que une loi de
programmation militaire dans un pays
comme le nôtre s'inscrit aussi sur un
bel héritage c'est quand même un pays
racinaire c'est une armée qui est
ancienne
qui a évidemment son histoire et donc
considérer que notre génération de
responsables politiques ou même
militaire on réécrirait tout sur la base
une page blanche je serai évidemment
complètement faux et ça c'est quand même
aussi notre force évidemment collective
c'est que on s'appuie sur des choses
déjà existantes alors vous me direz
c'est pas parce que ça existe déjà qu'il
faut le poursuivre aussi de l'arrêter ou
au contraire l'accélérer accélérer je
reviendrai néanmoins on voit bien quand
même qu'il y a quelques fondamentaux que
c'était le PM doit consolider pour
l'avenir son quoi tous nos propos sur
les sauts technologiques les menaces de
demain ne seront pas crédibles sur déjà
pas capables de prendre soin de ce que
les grands anciens nous ont laissé
déjà le premier commentaire amène à dire
que la réparation continue je pense dire
qu'on a une LPM de réparation puis
ensuite une elle peut me transformation
on le dit c'est assez vrai mais en fait
l'arrêter c'est que dans les forces
la réalité cette réparation ne se voit
que maintenant et puis pour celles et
ceux qui ont été élus locaux au fond et
pas tellement de différence sur la
commande publique dans une mairie la
commande publique pour le ministère des
armées certains égards ça prend du temps
et donc une inertie entre le moment où
vous enclenchez un certain nombre de
programmes et le moment il se voit sur
le terrain ça veut dire que cette
réparation elle va continuer je cite
peut-être trois exemples de exclusifs
mais qui viendront illustrer un peu
cette affaire là un les infrastructures
dont vous vous déplacez tous et toutes
beaucoup dans les forces et vous voyez
que nos bases aériennes régiment au base
navale sont pas toujours dans un état
florissant c'est le mot qu'on puisse
dire et donc il faut continuer à le
faire nous sommes en plus un ministère
qui n'est pas toujours
exemplaire en matière de passoire
énergétique c'est le moins qu'on puisse
dire aussi bon bref il y a toute une
famille de sujets autour des infras
qu'elles soient purement militaires ou
qu'elle soit AD militaires qui est un
sujet redoutable y compris
budgétairement et donc je vous annonce
que dans cette loi de programmation
militaire une somme de 16 milliards
d'euros contre 12 milliards d'euros sur
la période précédente sera débloqué pour
justement accélérer les projets
d'infrastructures la deuxième des choses
c'est évidemment le maintien conditions
opérationnelle
c'est le syndrome de l'hélicoptère qui
décolle pas c'est ce qu'on appelle la
disponibilité du matériel une fois plus
les commissaires à la défense sont
aguerris à ce sujet je le dis aussi
penser à ceux qui sont avec nous dans le
public ou qui nous regarderaient par les
moyens de télétransmission il est
évident que le maintien en condition
opérationnel est un des enjeux majeurs
aussi surtout programmation militaire un
enjeu qui doit quand même aussi être
capé budgétairement puisqu'on peut pas
non plus avoir du matériel qui coûte au
bout de deux ou trois années 6 fois le
prix deux fois le prix au moins en tout
cas deux fois le prix d'un matériel neuf
donc c'est là le ratio entre l'entretien
de ce matériel et son prix d'acquisition
initiale un sujet sur lequel on pourra
évidemment revenir et le troisième
exemple que je donne c'est évidemment
les stocks de munitions je suis rapide
sur ce sujet parce que vous avez là déjà
la interrogé par deux auditions sur
cette affaire et donc je voulais
réitérer l'engagement que j'avais pris
devant vous puisqu'on va aller vers une
copie à plus 45% par rapport à la LPM
précédente qui était déjà elle-même en
augmentation sur la question des stocks
de munitions pour porter l'effort à 16
milliards d'euros sur l'ensemble de la
période qui donne une visibilité pour
les munitions complexes et non complexes
assez inédites ensuite évidemment c'est
une loi de programmation militaire qui
doit aussi consacrer j'espère que ça
sera consensuel
le fait que notre armée est une armée
d'emploi
toutes les armées d'Europe ne sont pas
désormais d'emploi j'arrêterai mon
propos là puisque vous avez déjà eu des
auditions ce matin
mais je dois avouer que notre histoire
c'est celle-ci et donc une armée
d'emploi par définition c'est une armée
dans lequel
évidemment déjà on a des enjeux de
recrutement et de fidélisation
le métier de combattant quand on sait
qu'on va vraiment combattre qu'on va
vraiment connaître le feu c'est pas
complètement la même chose que dans
d'autres systèmes pas une critique c'est
factuelle ça veut dire que là aussi la
militarité doit se défendre et donc il y
a des chantiers importants à mener
indemnitaires indiciaire indiciaire on
va le débuter seulement maintenant parce
que le temps manqué et puis on a laissé
aussi le CSFM se prononcer sur d'autres
sujets mais on va commencer à lancer
aussi des chantiers importants sur
l'indiciaire l'indemnitaire c'est
évidemment la poursuite de la nprm que
vous connaissez bien ou 2024 évidemment
le troisième volet de 318 millions
d'euros est intégré évidemment dans la
LPM que je vous propose retenez
peut-être un chiffre sur les affaires de
ressources humaines il est assez
spectaculaire la question RH pour faire
vite dans la LPM précédente c'est
87,4 milliards d'euros dans la copie que
je vous propose ce matin nous passons à
97,8 milliards d'euros c'est-à-dire + 12
% là on est sur des masses financières
qui sont importantes elle comprend
évidemment les revalisations pour un
indice qu'on a plus récemment et elle
s'inscrit sur un chemin d'emploi qui lui
est le même que la dernière fois 275 000
PACS sans oublier nos civils de la
défense parce que ils sont très
importants dans notre modèle on en parle
trop peu avec une promesse
d'augmentation de 6300 ETP pour la
période de la LPM à venir qui représente
d'ailleurs quelque chose comme 890
millions d'euros une armée d'emplois
c'est aussi une armée avec des tués et
des blessés merci aux contribution des
parlementaires dans les différents
groupes de travail là aussi je pourrais
répondre à vos questions vous avez vu
voir dans le texte alors évidemment je
présente juste titre voulait que je
vienne dès le lendemain du Conseil des
ministres où je n'ignore pas que vous
avez peu de temps pour consulter le
texte mais c'est le c'est le principe
d'être là dès le lendemain à votre
disposition c'est que tout le monde
intègre bien que le texte va encore
prendre du temps à être disséqué par
vous et je comprends très bien en tout
cas sur les tuiles et les blessés vous y
retrouver dans ma montre toutes les
propositions qui ont été faites dans les
groupes de travail financièrement déjà
sur le les accompagnements 169 millions
d'euros c'est la première fois qu'on
dégage une somme spécifique pour blessé
le d'habitude tout ça a été pris en
plafond en gestion et là au moins on
donne une visibilité il y aura pas
d'excus budgétaires à ce que les
indemnisations soient faites et surtout
dans le normatif vous avez dû le voir
vous avez des articles de loi qui
changent la donne notamment sur la
relation à la faute de l'État ou non et
donc on a inversé complètement la
manière dont le soldat blessé doit se
comporter peut se comporter et a le
droit de se comporter vis-à-vis de son
administration et pareil pour cette
aberration sur le trop-perçu de solde
pour un soldat mort pour la France dont
je vous rappelle que lorsqu'il n'avait
le malheur de perdre vie le 15 du mois
la ministration de manière automatique
demandée à la veuve aux parents que
sais-je ou veuf de rembourser trois
perçu une abomination administrative
elle est corrigée dans le texte que je
vous propose ce matin une armée d'emploi
c'est une armée avec des familles c'est
un des plus grands ministères avec des
mutations évidemment en tout cas il y a
beaucoup beaucoup de de flux je vous
confie je vous confirme une somme une
augmentation importante sur le plan
famille avec 750 millions d'euros et
dont la feuille de route avec les
collectivités territoriales va être
déclinée j'aurais l'occasion de d'y
revenir
et puis aussi c'est une armée avec des
réservistes sur lequel là aussi pas
l'occasion de d'y revenir parce que nous
l'avons fait dans les groupes de travail
à doc mais qui comprend évidemment les
mesures que vous aviez suggéré sur les
augmentations mais aussi sur les
évolution des critères d'aptitudes
physiques sur les évolutions également
en matière d'âge avec des effets
d'éviction vous avez des retraités de
l'arme qui avait une soixantaine
d'années et à qui on expliquait qu'il
fallait partir alors qu'ils voulaient
rester dans la réserve très franchement
ça n'a pas de sens pour pas parler de
force morale si on met des gens dehors
alors qu'ils ont envie de continuer et
qu'ils ont complètement l'aptitude
physique donc ça évidemment c'est
important et puis je citerai également
la passerelle les passerelles avec
évidemment l'actif bon l'héritage je
l'ai dit c'est beaucoup de l'humain et
sont évidemment les les différentes
forces morales c'est évidemment aussi
notre dissuasion nucléaire je fais le
pivot vers le matériel vers les
capacités tout doucement mais je
l'inscris aussi un peu différemment
parce que la dissuasion c'est pas que la
mise en œuvre de moyens techniques c'est
aussi des filières humaines
spécifique
prend la dissuasion comme étant un des
exemples aussi du savoir-faire français
être capable d'avoir nos propres
chaudières nucléaires pour nous
sous-marins et le porte-avions d'avoir
évidemment des programmes qui tient la
robustesse de cette dissuasion nucléaire
dont je vous le rappelle si besoin en
été qu'en plus nous avons cette
particularité de la mettre en œuvre seul
et complètement seul et de manière
autonome dans notre manière de faire et
ça évidemment c'est clé la dissuasion
c'est une part importante c'est 13%
globalement de de l'englobe globale on
est à peu près dans la même épure que la
dernière fois sauf que là évidemment on
a quand même un rendez-vous important
c'est la dissuasion du futur
au fond nous vivons sur la dissuasion
nucléaire que nos anciens nous ont
légués il y a 15 ou 20 ans et donc les
choix que nous allons faire maintenant
sont des choix évidemment qui vont avoir
un impact tant sur les vecteurs que pour
les missiles
en tout cas les bateaux les avions et
les missiles sur les différents
programmes qui vont autour je pourrais
évidemment répondre à vos questions dans
les limites sur les limites évidemment
du secret sur une audition retransmis et
évidemment c'est à partir de cette
dissuasion de notre voûte nucléaire
qu'il faut interroger notre modèle de
sécurité globale
au fond on sait très bien la dissuasion
défend et protège nos intérêts vitaux
sur des agressions éthiques donc il y a
pas besoin d'aller plus loin pour
comprendre que à partir de cette phrase
il y a donc un certain nombre de menaces
qui méritent d'être regardés par leur
spécificité je vous en citer un certain
nombre en les balayant peut-être
rapidement pour répondre peut-être aux
questions plus précises sachant que
certains déjà fait l'objet de discussion
en commission je pense qu'il y a une
urgence absolue ça sera mon premier
exemple à moderniser et à durcir notre
défense solaire sur toutes les couches
c'est vrai évidemment pour les menaces
sur le haut du spectre c'est évidemment
vrai si on a eu un petit drone c'est
encore plus vrai aussi puisque on le
sait très bien les Jeux Olympiques vont
nous obliger à une vigilance
particulière dans un schéma ou
malheureusement plus personne ne parle
du terrorisme en tout cas plus assez or
on sait que la menace est toujours belle
et bien présente qu'elle soit d'ailleurs
endogènes ou exogènes et une hybridité
là aussi malheureusement des menaces en
matière solaire qu'on ne peut pas ne pas
voir bon la défense seule R
je prends plein de choses pour
évidemment la détailler globalement on
va vers un patch en quelque sorte à 5
milliards d'euros pour la seule fonction
de défense sol r dans la copie qui vous
est présenté ce matin c'est à dire une
augmentation de 300 % 300 %, je vais
vous dire que ça veut dire qu'on partait
de loin et qu'on vivait au fond sur la
vie du programme santé ancienne
génération faire le futur ancienne
génération avec évidemment des stocks de
missiles qui parfois n'étaient pas
suffisamment disponibles ou des plans de
monter en capacité de la lutte antidrone
qui n'était pas suffisamment me
semble-t-il robuste c'est un point clé
sur lequel nous sommes attendus parce
que pour le coup les menaces une fois de
plus sont bel et bien présentes le
deuxième volet sur lequel l'occasion et
le président de la République lui-même
voudra y revenir en tant que chef des
armées c'est évidemment la tension
particulière sur les outre-mer les
outre-mer sont évidemment sur le
territoire national je le rappelle ce
que parfois après s'il y a des choses
parfois écrites on présente l'outre-mer
comme étant détaché du territoire
national ce qui est évidemment une faute
néanmoins c'est vrai que les
outre-merdes n'étant pas tout à coller à
l'Hexagone ils ont donc des menaces qui
sont spécifiques par leur environnement
régional parler de leur exposition
évidemment au réchauffement climatique
avec des risques régaliens divers et
variés pour aujourd'hui ou pour demain
qui sont très différents les uns des
autres et je rappelle en plus la
tyrannie des distances ou des
élongations la Guyane rendent comme le
Portugal la Polynésie française grande
comme l'Europe la Nouvelle-Calédonie
grande comme l’autriche il est évident
que sa présente des défis sur lequel il
faut que nous soyons au rendez-vous et
que là aussi parfois les outre-mer ont
fait l'objet de
rabots budgétaire important dans la
capacité à aller protéger à les défendre
sans oublier que les outre-mer sont
encore peut-être plus vulnérables à
l'hybridité pour des raisons que vous
comprenez bien et ça c'est évidemment un
point clé après on trouve aussi
différents risques li notamment aux flux
migratoires
au sabotage diverses et variés de de
câbles sous-marins de de au dîner
d'accès de route maritimes bref les
enjeux évidemment sont nombreux l'espace
est un point sur lequel évidemment nous
allons vous proposer de durcir fortement
notre notre posture dans un espace qu'on
puisse dire qui se militarise de plus en
plus dans lequel on voit bien qu'un
certain nombre de grandes puissances
entendent très vite on fait un champ de
compétition pour le coup je parlais des
programmes électoraux tout à l'heure
tous les candidats à la présidentielle
ont ressenti qu'il fallait évidemment
développer une ambition autour du
spatial c'est c'est bienheureux et donc
là je rappelle que beaucoup de choses
sont dual et parfois sont portés par le
civil pour le seul ministère des armées
pour le spatial militaire pur notamment
avec les programmes Yoda iris ou céleste
je vous fais une proposition de
programme autour de 6 milliards d'euros
pour la période à venir c'est à dire une
augmentation de 45% qui est là pour le
coup aussi quelque chose qui correspond
à ce que nous sommes en droit d'attendre
même si évidemment beaucoup d'efforts
ont été fait ces dernières années je le
disais ces jours-ci dans un média ce que
la Direction du renseignement militaire
est capable de produire aujourd'hui
comme Rense de compréhension et
d'observation des situations tactiques
et stratégiques aujourd'hui par rapport
il y a 10 ans et par rapport à 20 ans et
complètement spectaculaire voilà je
parle même pas de la première guerre du
Golfe sur lequel nous étions
complètement aveugle et dépendants des
Américains aujourd'hui ce n'est pas le
cas et cette stratégie de souveraineté
en matière de renseignement à l'écrit
parce que on peut pas avoir une
diplomatie éclairée si on n'a pas aussi
des capacités de compréhension du monde
qui soient complètement autonome mais ça
je pense qu'il faut qu'on continue
d'aller plus loin j'accélère peut-être
monsieur le Président parce que je vais
être le plus complet possible évidemment
des stratégies en matière de fond marin
en matière d'innovation j'avais déjà
répondu à des questions lors de la
précédente audition de cyber on a
commencé à développer les choses
globalement là aussi c'est pratiquement
4 milliards d'euros sur le cyber sachant
que c'est pas qu'une affaire d'argent
parce que c'est beaucoup une affaire
aussi de ressources humaines derrière
donc de compétences humaines de
savoir-faire et c'est une augmentation
de 300% sur le seul patch cyber le
renseignement j'en disais un mot en
parlant de la DM là aussi on a des
augmentations importantes avec un 5
milliards d'euros pour l'ensemble des
services de renseignement dont j'assume
la tutelle c'est-à-dire une augmentation
de plus de 60%. les forces spéciales
dont je voudrais avoir un mot
particulier d'autant plus que votre
rapporteur est issu des forces spéciales
et d'ailleurs tous ces rares fois dans
l'histoire de la République un
rapporteur d'une LPM sera ici de ses
forces là faudrait vérifier bon il y a
pas de schéma dans lequel les forces
spéciales ne sont pas les premières à
marcher il y a peu de doctrines
d'emplois y compris d'ailleurs pour
protéger notre disposition nucléaire
dans lequel les forces spéciales ne sont
pas sollicitées donc là pour le coup
pour moi c'est j'y tenais beaucoup ça va
être un effort de 2 milliards d'euros
pour les seules forces spéciales dans
les 5 ans qui viennent beaucoup
évidemment autour du matériel individuel
c'est pas ce qui coûte le plus cher pour
être honnête mais surtout évidemment des
capacités de se projeter je pense
évidemment très fort aux hélicoptères
sur lesquels on était parfois en
situation de fragilité et sur lequel
évidemment on vient on vient durcir les
choses évidemment les drones sur
lesquels j'avais répondu à nombreuses
questions à la fois précédente donc j'y
reviens pas je vous annonce peut-être la
somme 5 milliards d'euros pour la seule
famille des drones dans le la copie que
je vous présente ce matin c'est à dire
plus 100% alors ensuite nous avons
établi aussi pour sortir un peu du sol
territoire national outre-mer compris
nous avons évidemment regardé quels
étaient les quelles étaient les les
autres intérêts si j'ose dire que nous
serions amenés à défendre à devoir
défendre à l'extérieur du territoire
national
évacuation de ressortissants français
dans des pays en crise capacité
évidemment à sécuriser peut-être
certains espaces ou à dissuader c'est
évidemment ce que nous faisons comme
nation-card actuellement en Roumanie
capacité à garder des voies maritimes
ouvertes et disponibles je le disais
également là pour le coup c'est aussi la
capacité à emmener les autres on revait
peut-être aussi après à des aspects qui
seront moins consensuels entre les
différentes sensibilités politiques
parce que ça peut s'adosser évidemment à
notre à notre diplomatie et à la manière
dont on imagine le rôle de la France
dans le monde c'est au fond qu'est-ce
qu'on est capable de faire seul et si on
du monde est-ce qu'on est capable d'être
le chef de fil du monde qu'on emmène en
notant comme hors temps pour être très
clair donc ça c'est évidemment quelque
chose qui est clé le rapport annexé pour
le coup dit bien les objectifs pour pour
cette LPM moi je veux inciter deux
évidemment c'est là où je mets le
porte-avion ou je vois bien depuis le ce
week-end beaucoup d'interventions ils
ont offenses qu'on a vraiment besoin
d'un porte-avions etc on pourra revenir
sur ce point mais oui dans la mesure où
c'est la capacité à emmener une
coalition sur les mers et notamment et
peut-être particulièrement mer
Méditerranée et en océan Indien sur
lequel on a des intérêts évidemment
importants et la seule question du défi
de sécurité présente l'Iran à mon avis
notamment sur les voies maritimes donne
déjà quelque chose ce que ce qu'on
pourrait connaître demain évidemment
aussi enfin je répondrai à vos questions
quasiantes sur sur l'enjeu d'un groupe
héro naval et pour la remettre terre là
je vous confirme un objectif important
qui est une capacité à avoir dès 2027
c'est à dire au fond dans un temps assez
court désormais une division à deux
brigades donc classe 10 à 12000 ohms en
autonomie complète et une ambition de
corps d'armée en coalition en 2030 là
pour le coup on aura vraiment un avant
après si j'ose dire entre les 10 ans de
LPM
2017-2030 sur cette capacité à faire
puisque nous l'avions non pas perdu mais
en tout cas au prix d'un
d'effort qui sont très très difficile là
évidemment on serait dans une logique
d'endurance et de réactivité alors pour
terminer peut-être les conditions
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
rapporteur et madame messieurs les
députés les conditions de cette
transformation parce que je vais revenir
évidemment sur les questions financières
mais vous le voyez bien le budgétaire
est au service de l'ambition militaire
c'est aussi quand même ce qu'on a
cherché à faire
bien souvent comme il s'agissait de
diminuer brutalement les crédits
considérant que le ministère des armées
ne râle jamais forcément on pouvait pas
partir de l'ambition militaire ou en
tout cas c'était mentir au peuple
français là si on regarde bien c'est
quand même des conditions indispensables
pour réussir cette transformation la
première c'est qu'évidemment notre base
industrielle et technologique de défense
et imbriquer dans le modèle d'armée je
le redis parce que je frappé de voir
parfois aussi les commentaires sur 413
milliards ceux-ci cela enfin oui il
suffirait d'acheter à Washington pour
les uns peut-être à Moscou et qu'un pour
les autres pour que ça puisse coûter
moins cher faut mettre les pieds dans le
plat aussi une bonne fois pour toute
c'est à dire que il est évident que
avoir son propre modèle en autonomie a
aussi une forme de coût bon la
contrepartie c'est que ça crée aussi du
PIB puis ça ramène aussi de l’emploi sur
le territoire ça j'espère que ça sera
conscient fait d'entre nous ce qui ne
sera pas consensuel c'est le rapport aux
exportations d'armes de notre BITD mais
en tout cas sur le sol fait que notre
modèle coûte un peu plus cher que
d'autres modèles je ferai expliquer nos
concitoyens pourquoi sinon on leur dit
pas la vérité bon pareil d'ailleurs sur
les augmentations et les comparaisons
avec avec les autres pays tous les pays
de l'OTAN sont en train d'augmenter leur
capacité
d'achat d'armement mais rarement sur des
achats qui sont nationaux bon donc nous
par définition notre trajectoire
budgétaire ont un lien avec l'industrie
lequel industrie a un lien que la
trajectoire budgétaire tout ça ayant un
lien avec l'export si on ne fait pas le
catéchisme républicain de modèle
industriel et de notre modèle d'armée
évidemment on y perd on y perd nos
petits ça veut dire aussi qu'il faut que
la BITD bouge en même temps que l'armée
française et les armées françaises ont
bougé c'est évidemment tout ce qui
tourne autour de l'économie de guerre
dont vous retrouvez évidemment suite au
groupe de travail un certain nombre de
propositions dans la programmation
militaire sur le champ normatif
réquisition droit de priorisation enfin
ce sont quand même des outils en cas de
grande dégradation de notre sécurité
c'est pas des outils par principe
ce qui compte désormais c'est que on
puisse tenir les prix les délais
la capacité évidemment à avoir du stock
et la capacité à produire dans des flux
tendus si besoin en été c'est d'autant
plus clé que les pays à l'export le
réclameront comme étant aussi un des
conditions importantes je vous l'avais
dit lors de la pression tout audition
quand même la Pologne on connaît le
relation que la Pologne a avec les
USA quand même la Pologne décide
d'acheter en Corée du Sud parce qu'il
trouve que l'industrie américaine ne
livre pas assez vite ça doit être une
alerte et un signal qu'il faut entendre
donc c'est aussi une opportunité pour
notre industrie de défense dont je
rappelle que si on exporte pas en
équilibre pas le modèle donc là c'est
plus 413 milliards d'euros on a encore
sur une autre galaxie et ou une autre
relation ou alors faut recréer des
arsenaux mais enfin c'est en tout cas
c'est plus tout à fait le modèle actuel
j'estime qu'en plus au regard du rapport
annexé l'industrie de défense désormais
la visibilité
je pense que et à la hausse je pense que
ça fait longtemps que c'était pas arrivé
donc là il y a les conditions de succès
sur lesquelles je pourrais aussi revenir
bon la deuxième des choses ce sont
évidemment des ressources
413 milliards d'euros c'est beaucoup
d'argent je pense qu'il faut leur gueule
en tout cas sachez que les armées que
j'ai l'honneur de
représenter devant vous à certains
égards
sont conscientes de l'effort qu'on
demande à la nation je pense que les
petites musiques qui laissent entendre
que les militaires veulent toujours plus
d'argent que c'est jamais assez etc non
je pense qu'au contraire les forces
armées sont soucieuses aussi d'avoir
quelque chose qui soit soutenable et qui
soit comprise par l'ensemble de nos
concitoyens et ça je peux vous assurer
qu'il n'y a pas de de déni sur cette
affaire là je reviens pas sur 413 400
milliards j'imagine que vous me
reposerez la question déjà longuement
répondu la dernière fois sur les
ressources extra budgétaires
j'estime aussi que notre devoir même si
parfois la vie politique peut conduire à
se faire plaisir c'est aussi
[Musique]
la trajectoire qui vous est proposée au
fond on passe de 32 milliards d'euros
budget annuel du ministère des armées en
2017 à 69 milliards d'euros en 2030 et
2/3 du chemin se fera sous les deux
quinquennats d'Emmanuel Macron alors
j'entends déjà des craintes en disant
mais qu'est-ce qui va se passer entre 27
et 30 bah ça faudra poser la question
différents candidats avec son
présidentielle en 2027 aussi ce qu'il
s'engage à poursuivre cet effort-là il y
a quelque chose de curieux en disant que
parce qu'on a peur que d'autres ne
tiennent pas parole ensuite il faudrait
précipiter la charge et le patchage
aujourd'hui
d'autant plus curieux que quand les
crédits augmentent parfois cela fait
l'objet de plus de commentaires que
lorsque jadis il diminuer
vous devant vous un ancien maire et
ancien président de département qui a
connu suffisamment de fermetures il y a
quelques années de ça pour savoir à quel
point tout cela n'est quand même pas
très agréable désormais il y a ni
fermeture et il y a que des perspectives
il y a aussi des étalons de programme et
ça je veux dire un mot devant vous parce
que je pense qu'il faut les assumer
sauf évidemment à entrer dans une
posture complètement démagogique mais il
faut les assumer parce que nous avons
aussi cherché à sincériser la copie que
les industriels c'est-à-dire en clair la
capacité à produire sur cette exécution
de LPM et un certain nombre de vous vous
y êtes revenu lors des auditions
budgétaires de l'automne dernier on voit
bien que parfois bah on se dit mais
pourquoi il y a autant de marge
frictionnelles ou pourquoi vous avez du
report de charge c'est plutôt pour
l'inflation mais pourquoi vous avez des
marges frictionnelles et pourquoi
parfois il y a quelques décalages tout
simplement parce que le crédit de
paiement intervient au moment où on se
fait livrer le matériel aussi simple que
ça et donc typiquement sur le programme
scorpion pour ne citer que cet exemple
on a eu un dialogue exigeant avec Nexter
sur la capacité à produire des Césars à
la capacité à produire des jaguars la
capacité à produire des griffons pour le
citer et le serval pour ne citer que ces
quatre exemplaires mais qui sont clés et
il est évident qu'on a recomposé aussi
le programme parce que ce qui compte
pour les armées et ce qui compte pour
mon ministère c'est évidemment de
s'assurer de l'irréversibilité de ces
programmes il est clair que là la
scorpionisation de l'armée de terre est
en route et que si vous votez cette toit
de programmation militaire elle est
acquise de manière irréversible et que
donc évidemment vous avez des programmes
qui parfois basculeuront 2030 2031 2032
mais comme dans toutes les lois de
programmation depuis 1960
et là aussi parfois surpris de voir des
commentaires au fond de manière scolaire
il faudrait aïe tout est fini à la date
dite non le programmation militaire
n'ont jamais fonctionné comme ça et pour
cause elle servait à mener des grands
programmes et notamment la dissuasion
nucléaire et donc par définition était
plus réelle et obligé souvent aussi
d'ailleurs les successeurs à tenir les
engagements passés en tout cas je crois
que même le général logo a eu cette idée
pour contraindre un peu George Pompidou
donc il est clair que ce n'est pas
médiocre comme conversation que de
regarder la vie des programmes et leur
plurianualité je pense que c'est un
point évidemment important l'inflation
était intégrée j'avais répondu à
l'ensemble de vos questions précédemment
l'inflation on en parle quand elle est
quand elle est négative pour les armées
quand elle était positive et qu'il y
avait du bourrage évidemment ça n'est
mauvais personne ce qu'il faut désormais
c'est évidemment la remettre à jour
régulièrement cette copie là vous avez
globalement tous les facteurs les plus
pessimistes ont été retenus ça veut dire
que ça ça fait la famille à peu près 30
milliards d'euros en impact sur
l'ensemble de la copie bon moi j'ai des
échanges réguliers avec Bercy vous en
doutez
il y a quand même quelques prévisions
d'inflation parce que l'inflation sur
les matières premières alimentaires n'a
rien à voir avec nos affaires donc là
aussi parfois les choses un peu bizarres
dans les articles bon donc là il est
clair qu'il faut qu'on arrive à regarder
ça en annualité budgétaire ce qui
explique le fait que je vais revenir
devant vous en vous demandant en
collectivement budgétaire une ouverture
de crédit 1,5 milliards d'euros pour
l'année 23 passons donc de la marche à 3
milliards d'euros à 4,5 milliards
d'euros pour nous permettre de traiter
certains sujets d'inflation où je j'ai
pas envie de décaler des programmes au
regard de la situation que nous
connaissons et donc je plutôt que de
décaler un programme je préfère demander
au Parlement qui dira oui qui dira non
une somme supplémentaire et qu'en plus
nous avons quelques enjeux sur la
défense solaire dont je vous entretenez
tout à l'heure notamment sur la lutte
anti-drone qui évidemment nécessite
quelques achats urgents aussi pour le MI
KVL notamment pour donner qu'un exemple
très concret pour les Jeux Olympiques et
c'est évidemment maintenant qu'il faut
lancer les affaires puisqu'il sera
évidemment trop tard au début de l'année
2024 pour l'intégrer dans la marche
qu'il y a donc il faut imaginer ces
marches telles qu'elles vous sont
présentées de mon point de vue monsieur
le Président comme un plancher et non
pas comme un plafond en tout cas je
pense que c'est comme ça qu'il faut il
faut le regarder voilà
mesdames messieurs les députés ce que je
pouvais vous dire
sachant qu'évidemment comme je vous l'ai
dit le sujet est énorme donc il peut
nécessiter des développements sur des
points divers et variés évidemment je me
tiendrai à la disposition de l'Assemblée
nationale autant qu'il le faudra ainsi
que les différents chefs d'état-major
qui ont l'occasion de venir devant la
Commission de la Défense dans un format
plus discret pour leur permettre d'avoir
une parole libre devant vous mais
évidemment pour que ils puissent vous
rendre compte aussi de la manière dont
ils imaginent pour leur armée pour la
DGA le cas échéant la manière de voir
les choses pour citer le PM puisque
c'est politique qui endos c'est
politique qui fait des choix mais enfin
ce sont quand même les forces armées qui
ont préparé cette fête programmation
militaire elle ne tombe pas du ciel
merci Monsieur le Ministre alors mes
chers collègues nous avons déjà de
nombreuses demandes de prise de parole
et afin de pouvoir toutes les prendre
les interventions du rapporteur et des
orateurs de groupe seront limités à deux
minutes avec ré pour 6 et les autres
questions seront limitées à une minute
la parole est à notre rapporteur
Jean-Michel Jacques merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Ministre la loi de
programmation militaire est une loi
singulière c'est naturellement un outil
planification financière indispensable
pour nos armées contenu du temps lent
dans laquelle s'inscrivent les
programmes d'équipement mais c'est aussi
et peut-être surtout la traduction de
notre ambition stratégique de la place
que la France souhaite tenir dans les
jeux des puissances pour parapher le
général de Gaulle une LPM incarne
assurément une certaine idée de la
France or le présent de projet loi de
programmation militaire que vous venez
de présenter monsieur le ministre et
dont je suis le rapporteur a précisément
pour ambition de mettre notre nation
au plus haut niveau et de tenir son rond
c'est à dire notre d'autonomie d'analyse
de décision et d'action
et ceci dans un contexte stratégique
dominé non seulement par le retour des
conflits interétathiques mais aussi par
le développement de nouveaux champs de
conflictualité maintenir notre autonomie
de décision et d'action cela signifie en
premier chef être en capacité de
protéger en toute circonstances nos
concitoyens et notre territoire en
métropole mais aussi en outre-mer à ce
sujet que vous avez évoqué dans votre
propos liminaire pourriez-vous nous
préciser monsieur le ministre ce que
prévoit le projet de loi de
programmation militaire pour consolider
la protection de nos territoires
d'outre-mer et notre zone économique
exclusive qui est rappelant-le la
deuxième la plus importante du monde je
vous remercie merci Monsieur le Ministre
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Rapporteur bon
outre-mer il y a des points communs sur
la copie outre-mer pour tous les
territoires il y a des points
spécifiques le point commun quand je
parlais de mauvais état des
infrastructures s'il y a bien des
endroits dans lequel franchement il faut
faire un point d'effort majeur sur les
infras c'est bien en outre-mer et donc
globalement sur la période sur le budget
infra dont je vous parlais tout à
l'heure c'est 800 millions d'euros
uniquement pour les territoires
ultramarins sur les infras la deuxième
des choses évidemment c'est le format
humain puisque souvent cette chose est
trop méconnue de de nos concitoyens mais
globalement on a une classe autour de
9000 hommes
présents en outre-mer pour des fonctions
d'ailleurs très différentes
il est clair que les missions de
chicandra à Mayotte ou darpille en
Guyane et je vais avoir une pensée pour
le militaire du GIGN qui a perdu la vie
et d'ailleurs aussi pour le
sapeur-pompier de la BSPP de Paris qui
servait à Kuroko qui a aussi perdu la
vie malheureusement en Guyane de
militaire en peu de temps
montre à quel point quand même les
militaires qui sont déployés dans les
Territoires d'Outre cours des risques et
donc il est clair que il faut ensuite on
arrive à regarder les missions pour moi
des grands enjeux c'est de cibler le
meilleur des segments technologiques sur
l'outre-mer dans les années qui vont
venir notamment pour assurer et assumer
notre souveraineté souveraineté dans les
zones économiques exclusives je parlais
des risques liés au réchauffement
climatiques je pense que les prédations
maritimes les prédations sur les
réserves aliotiques notamment dans le
Pacifique sont des choses qui doivent
nous préoccuper aujourd'hui la Marine
nationale est capable d'exercer cela
mais au prix d'efforts qui sont
importants et on le voit bien les drones
de demain les capacités spatiales de
demain nous permettront évidemment
d'avoir des moyens d'observation et donc
d'exécution de cette souveraineté qui
sera beaucoup plus forte ce sont des
exemples que je vous donne en tout cas
ils sont dans la copie troisième volet
pour essayer de synthétique quatrième
plutôt pour essayer d'être synthétique
il est clair que la question des
transports des élongations est un sujet
clé là la copie à 400 m tel que vous est
proposée dans le rapport annexé intègre
des affectations moyen propre à
l'Outre-mer hexagone outremer mais aussi
entre les territoires d'outre-mer je
pense que tous les commissaires à la
défense qui ont été amenés à se déplacer
ont été confrontés au vieillissement du
Kaza au vieillissement de nos vieux Puma
c'est moins qu'on puisse dire et donc là
pour le coup en terme de disponibilité
de moyens aériens plus encore peut-être
que maritime puisque maritime la LPM
précédente prévoit des choses et les
patrouilleurs arrivent vous avez dû voir
qu'elle Nouméa on a une livraison de
bateaux qui s'est faite cette semaine la
copie maritime vous la connaissez donc
elle faut la consolider c'est de
l'argent gâteau avaler n'a plus de goût
donc considère que c'est déjà lancé mais
enfin là vous retrouverez les crédits de
paiement dans les 413 milliards d'euros
en tout cas sur le volet armé de l'air
ou alors la latte il y a clairement des
enjeux là qu'il faut qu'il faut pouvoir
développer pour les territoires
d'outre-mer voilà en synthèse on aura
l'occasion d'y revenir merci monsieur le
ministre pour le groupe Renaissance la
parole est à Mounir benamity merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre je vous remercie pour votre
présentation claire et ambitieuse de
cette loi de programmation militaire
2024-2030 que le groupe Renaissance sout
et soutiendra au cours des futurs
travaux de la commission de la défense
évidemment en séance dans l'hémicycle
comme vous l'avez souligné cette LPM est
nécessaire pour assurer la résilience de
nos armées face au contexte géopolitique
actuel la guerre de haute intensité et
de retour sur le sol européen être en
mesure d'y faire face n'est pas un choix
c'est pour nous un devoir il nous faut
donc programmer des investissements
massifs adopter une économie de guerre
condition de l'efficacité de nos armées
et de notre crédibilités stratégiques la
construction du porte-avion de nouvelle
générations est une démonstration forte
de la volonté de cette LPM de renforcer
et moderniser nos armées pour pérenniser
notre autonomie stratégique et notre
crédibilité opérationnelle vous avez
évoqué monsieur le ministre une
cathédrale technologique je souhaiterais
donc évoquer avec vous la conception de
ce géant des mers la construction du
porte-avions nucléaire de nouvelle
génération constitue un défi
technologique d'envergure pour
l'industrie française
ce chantier devrait se dérouler en
grande partie dans les bassins des
Chantiers de l'Atlantique de
Saint-Nazaire il se pose comme une
vitrine de l'excellence de la bit des
Françaises ce projet doit également
inclure l'ensemble de notre filière
industrielle de défense je pense
évidemment à nos TPE PME et anneaux
start-up innovantes ces entreprises
irriquent irriguent l'économie de nos
territoires et j'ai eu l'occasion de
visiter la start-up innovante acrivia
incubé à l'École Centrale de Nantes
cette entreprise nantaise a développé un
système unique de découpe plasma qui
pourraient s'avérer fortement utiles
dans le chantier du futur porte-avion de
la conception à la construction ce
projet offre l'opportunité d'enrichir
notre filière industrielle de défense à
condition que nous accompagnons ces
entreprises innovantes alors comment
garantir à l'ensemble de ces acteurs de
notre filière industriel française a
commencé par nos startups innovantes
comme à krivia leur embarquement si
j'ose dire dans ce chantier historique
et pour y anticiper pour y participer
ces entreprises se doivent d'être prêtes
pour un tel défi notamment sur le plan
des financements comment garantir leurs
conditions les conditions de leur
croissance d'ici au début de la
conception et de la construction du PNG
voilà deux questions auxquelles il nous
faudra répondre ensemble je vous
remercie monsieur le ministre en deux
minutes
j'essaie de
PNG on pourra y revenir mais de fait
c'est quand même j'ai tenu à être très
clair dans les colonnes du Parisien
dimanche parce que il y a pas de grands
programmes majeurs sans grande
visibilité et compris pour les
différentes entreprises y compris pour
la gestion des ressources humaines y
compris pour les emplois qui vont
derrière donc je l'ai fait aussi parce
que parfois quelques rumeurs circulant
ici ou là vous pouvez créer une forme de
doute donc c'est vrai pour technique
atome je reviens pas sur la nécessité de
garder des savoir-faire importants sur
la propulsion nucléaire c'est absolument
clé pour moi et pour nous tous je
l'imagine évidemment pour les sujets
liés à la construction en tant que tel
et donc évidemment STX ou naval group
donc la visibilité étant donné c'est
aussi une bonne nouvelle pour votre
territoire accessoirement puisque
évidemment ça donne aussi de la
visibilité sur sur les chantiers non sur
les PME et sur l'innovation pour moi
c'est absolument clé je pense qu'il y a
deux choses à faire bon charité bien
ordonné commence par soi-même je pense
qu'il faut que nous même ministère des
armées on balaie devant notre porte dans
la capacité à permettre au PME de se
brancher directement sur la commande
publique du ministère des armées tout le
monde me dit que c'était encore trop
compliqué donc c'est pour moi un des
points d'attention sur lequel j'ai
demandé au DGA de prendre ça à bras le
corps mais aussi aux armées parce que on
parlait des forces spéciales il y a
parfois des plateaux techniques qui
permettent justement de brancher
directement des PME innovantes pour un
certain nombre de segments on voit bien
que la ID a fait un boulot remarquable
depuis sa création nommé le nouveau
patron de l'idée en succession
évidemment d'Emmanuel qui va le patch
globalement innovation c'est 10
milliards à la main de la idée ou pas
loin de la idée pour faire vite dans la
dans l'alpm à venir et puis enfin pour
être synthétique le troisième défi c'est
que les grands les grands arbres de la
BITD soit particulièrement bienveillant
et intégrant dans leur suplight chaîne
avec l'ensemble de ces PME et là il y a
aussi une marge de manœuvre mais pour
que je puisse évidemment leur mettre
amicalement la pression il faut aussi
que le ministère des armées montre
davantage d'exemples dans les temps qui
viendront voilà en synthèse merci
monsieur le ministre pour le groupe
rassemblement national la parole
Caroline Colombier merci monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre monsieur
le rapporteur chers collègues je vous
remercie de votre exposé qui bien sûr
reprend déjà probablement quelques
questions et réponses que j'aimerais
évoquer la loi de programmation
militaire 2019-2025 représentait une
évolution nécessaire et bienvenue même
si elle n'aura pas suffi à totalement
résorber les sous investissements
chroniques de nos armées depuis la fin
de la guerre froide infrastructure
vétust ou inadapté importante difficulté
de fidélisation des effectifs
préparations opérationnelle insuffisante
problèmes de disponibilité des matériels
sans parler des surcoûts engendrés par
les Opex les enjeux sont lourds nous
espérions que cette LPM y répondrait
d'autant que la conflictualité accrue du
monde impose de se préparer à des
guerres de haute intensité avec 413
milliards d'euros de budget annoncés
étalés sur 7 ans le chant des possibles
était ouvert seulement voilà si les
constats sont partagés les moyens
annoncés sont tout de même décevants sur
le volet financier le compte n'y est pas
l'essentiel des grandes marges
budgétaires supplémentaires viendront à
côté de à compter de 20 en somme vous
faites des promesses qui n'engageront
que vos successeurs sur 413 milliards
certes montant en hausse par rapport aux
précédentes à la précédente LPM 13 ne
sont pas budgétées et s'appuient sur des
recettes supplémentaires floues et peu
crédibles cette LPM est d'ores et déjà
compromise par l'inflation monsieur le
ministre vous confirmez vous-même
qu'elle pèsera hauteur de 30 milliards
d'euros sur le budget total un détail en
résumé cette LPM ce chiffre en réalité à
plus ou moins 370 milliards d'euros
chaque armée cumulera des retards retard
sur scorpion pour l'armée de l'air de
terre nombre de frégates et de
patrouilleurs insuffisants pour la
marine non renouvellement total en
rafale de la flotte de chasse et retarde
dans la livraison des viandes de
transport le manque qu'on puisse dire
c'est que nous restons tout de même sur
notre fin cette LPM ne résoudra donc pas
les problématiques de fidélisation et de
vétusté des infrastructures l'absence de
filières munitionnaire souveraine
l'enlisement des coopérations
européennes telles que SCAF ou mgcs
alors pour rester optimiste je vous le
demande monsieur le ministre êtes-vous
prêt à prendre en compte les
propositions du Parlement pour que cette
LPM répondrait réellement aux enjeux de
notre défense nationale face à la haute
intensité ayant de hautes ambitions et
que vive l'Armée merci
merci beaucoup oui on va évidemment
écouter le Parlement bon pour reprendre
tout petit frutti l'ensemble des des
points que vous avez évoqué dire qu'on
fait reposer sur nos successeurs
l'effort c'est déjà ce qui était dit en
2017 bon avec des marches qui étaient
d'un peu plus d'un milliard et en disant
bah oui la marche à 3 milliards de toute
façon vous la renvoyer sur la suite bon
mais sauf que la suite c'est nous puis
on continue de l'intégrer donc je vois
pas pourquoi enfin quand les crédits
diminuaient quand on n'était pas dans un
escalier avec des marches pour monter
mais dans un toboggan qui avait été
installé pour permettre au ministère des
armées de glisser joyeusement personne
ne soucier de la brutalité avec laquelle
ça diminué je le dis quand même pour la
mémoire collective c'est important de se
le dire deuxième des choses bah oui
enfin il est quand même normal que sur
une LPM entre 24 et 30 il y a quand même
une part de l'effort à faire entre 27 et
30 ou alors ça revient à dire que vous
doutez par exemple de la capacité à
Madame Le Pen d'augmenter les crédits
budgétaires si elles devaient être
présents dans la République entre 27 et
bon donc je pense que les lois de
programmation militaires quand les
gaullistes ont voté les premières lois
de programmation militaires il ne serait
pas qui était Président de la République
ensuite et pour autant ils ont quand
même lancé le coup de la dissuasion
nucléaire sur aux pratiquesment 20 ans
puisque c'est le président Giscard
d'Estaing qui globalement a vu les
premiers séné-le à la mer entre le
moment où c'était décidé par Pierre
Messmer et le moment il les a vu de
toute façon la plus réunionalité elle
compte 3 la hauteur des marches on peut
en discuter évidemment je n'ai pas de
tabou sur cette affaire si ce n'est
quand même la soutenabilité pour nos
finances publiques parce que les effets
d'annonces sont quand même là mais après
derrière il faut les écouter les marges
que je vous propose je suis sûr qu'on
les exécute
si vous vous estimez alors après il y a
quelques économies ailleurs tout ça très
bien enfin la réalité c'est que je je
suis moi redevable aussi de cette parole
devant les armées les marches qui sont
proposées sont compatibles avec la
trajectoire des finances publiques du
pays
ensuite si on veut aller sur des marges
plus élevées
faut dire aussi pourquoi parce que c'est
pas vrai de dire que on aura des retards
étaler ce n'est pas complètement que
tout retarder et pour cause parce que
parfois nous industriels ne sont pas en
capacité d'aller beaucoup plus vite
alors si vous augmentez des marches pour
derrière avoir de la non exécution alors
ça c'est sûr que c'est c'est sympathique
ça permet de faire un peu de politique
mais globalement ce n'est pas crédible
sur le terrain militaire donc moi
j'assume aussi la copie telle qu'elle
vous êtes proposé et d'ailleurs si c'est
pas 3000 arbres pour les premières
années ça serait combien selon vous et
sur quel programme et pour faire quoi je
pense qu'il faut aller jusqu'au bout
parce que s'il faut écouter le Parlement
faut au-delà des effets plus vite plus
forts plus loin très bien c'est facile
mais pourquoi faire ça ça me semble clé
sur le terrain militaire puisque je le
rappelle les pays qui augmentent fort
leur budget militaire autour de nous
sont souvent pour acheter du matériel à
l'étranger notamment aux États-Unis
comme nous nous le ferons pas par
définition il faut brancher une
ressource budgétaire et notre capacité à
acheter sur la capacité industrielle
française ça c'est une réalité ou alors
c'est un autre modèle d'armée que vous
voulez
mais ça faut le dire ou alors vous
souhaitez un deuxième porte-avion auquel
cas effectivement 413 c'est pas assez
mais il faut aller jusqu'au bout
c'est-à-dire que parler que des sommes
sans parler de ce qu'on veut sur le
terrain militaire ça ne peut pas
fonctionner c'est là où je serai à
l'écoute du Parlement mais il faut être
cohérent parce que parfois évidemment ça
prend du temps mais si je vous dis aussi
une chose si les crédits n'avaient pas
diminué dans le passé on n'aurait pas
besoin de les augmenter c'est aussi la
vérité de la Palisse et ça évidemment
c'est quelque chose qui prend du temps
l'inflation elle est intégrée donc quand
tu dis qu'elle est intégrée c'est que
l'aéroport de charges sont là et on en
est fait la démonstration pour 2023
entre les reports de charge les marges
frictionnelles plus l'argent qu'on a
réinjecté en gestion un milliard d'euros
en 2022 1,5 milliards d'euros en 2023
montrez-moi ce qui a été retardé par
l'inflation sur 22 23 si je suis à
l'écoute du Parlement je veux aussi une
lettre factuellement montrez-moi les
programmes qui ont été retardés par
l'inflation en 10 mois voilà
montrez-les-moi je je serais heureux de
l'entendre donc ça je vous en ferai
aussi de la démonstration en tout cas de
bonne foi et je crois que c'est
important sur filaire munitionnaire
national vous avez dû voir que j'avais
annoncé la localisation pour le coup du
filière poudre pour les obus de 155 mm
sur les usines de rinco de Bergerac donc
le travail d'économie de guerre il se
fait il prend du temps et on pratique
pratiquement 8 projets relocalisation
qui sont en cours de discussion à
négociation en ce moment merci monsieur
le ministre pour le groupe la France
insoumise la parole est à Bastien
Lachaud merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre comment porter au
plus haut pour la France et pour le
monde un certain dont elle est
enveloppée les chances de paix et si
malgré son effort et sa volonté de paix
elle est attaquée comment porter au plus
haut les chances de salut les moyens de
victoire la question que posait Jean
Jaurès en 1911 est toujours celle à
laquelle nous devons répondre
aujourd'hui
votre texte est-il à la hauteur des
enjeux nous avons d'abord un enjeu de
souveraineté de la nation qui ne se
limite pas à la BITD le concept de
l'économie de guerre en temps de paix n'
n'y répond pas complètement en outre la
défense de la France ne s'arrête pas à
l'Hexagone et aux conséquences de la
guerre sur le continent européen
présente dans tous les océans grâce à
ses territoires ultramarins la France
doit veiller à consolider ses relations
régionales et protéger ses aide la
France grande nation spatiale et
maritime doit tenir son rang dans ses
nouvelles frontières de l'humanité que
sont l'espace les fonds marins et le
cyber face à ces enjeux que nous
proposez-vous
revenons sur les marches budgétaires la
presse s'est fait écho de votre volonté
de les voir débuter à 5 milliards vous
sembliez alors savoir comment utiliser
un tel montant les arbitrages semblent
vous avoir été malheureusement
défavorable finalement ce seront donc 3
milliards jusqu'à la fin du quinquennat
Macron soit une dynamique similaire à
celle prévue par la LPM 2019-2025
comment l'expliquer alors que vous
invoquiez l'urgence d'une nouvelle LPM
pire avec l'inflation vous nous
présentez des marches qui sont
inférieures en valeur réelle à celle
prévue par la LPM 2019-2025
j'espère que les débats au Parlement
permettront de modifier cela de plus
vous nous indiquez que les marches sont
des planchers et non des plafonds depuis
quand une LPM présente-t-elle des
planchers les armées devront-elles
attendre chaque PLF pour connaître leur
budget mais alors à quoi sert la LPM
normalement à planifier organiser des
programmes complexes donner de la
visibilité aux industriels si les
budgets varient année après année cela
n'est plus le cas une LPM sert
normalement à organiser si ce n'est pas
le cas vous allez plutôt désorganiser
dans tous les cas soyez assurés que le
groupe de la France insoumise nups sera
force de proposition durant l'examen de
ce projet de LPM afin de permettre à la
France d'être indépendante et au service
de la paix et que vive la République
Monsieur le Ministre oui heureux de vous
retrouver monsieur le député Lachaux
tant mieux en tout cas si la France
insoumise sera
de proposition parce que en fait on peut
toujours parler des sommes pendant des
heures moi je crois heureux de
comprendre aussi quels sont vos
propositions pour cette reprogrammation
militaire sur le terrain militaire non
mais sur le terrain militaire parce que
je peux toujours faire ce qu'on veut
avec les sommes je comprends que les
oppositions soient gênées avec l'effort
que nous faisons avec ces 413 milliards
c'est certain que on enlève une partie
de l'oxygène sur la rhétorique des
opposants donc ça va pas si vite ça va
pas assez loin les marches ça sera de
bonne guerre et je me livrerai bien
volontiers à cet exercice là je n'ai
jamais proposé des marches à 5 jamais
non mais vous avez raison de me poser la
question parce que vous avez raison de
lire la presse et moi j'ai raison de
vous répondre jamais je n'ai proposé de
marche à 5 jamais voilà je considère
véritablement que la soutenabilité et
j'ouvrir une chose même une marche à 5
je serais venu devant vous avec derrière
des crédits de paiement non exécuté
parce que quand avec une marche à 5
n'aurait pas plus de satellites plus
vite avec une marche à 5 vous
n'avancerez pas votre programme
Barracuda plus vite avec des marches à 5
vous n'accélérez pas votre programme
décennies le 3G plus vite avec une
marche à 5 vous n'accélérez pas le
nouveau programme notamment pour le PNG
la réalité c'est que les grosses masses
financières elles sont essentiellement
sur les programmes à effet majeur et
vous le savez très bien or par
définition plus d'argent ne fait pas
avancer plus vite certains programmes
pour des raisons évidentes ou alors on
est sur des épures de quelques centaines
de millions d'euros mais pas des
milliards non mais donc après une fois
de plus je vois bien la gêne que tout
cela peut créer en tout cas moi ce que
je serai de comprendre aussi c'est quoi
votre modèle armée si on sort de l'OTAN
ça ça me semble intéressant parce que
c'est plus complètement les mêmes sommes
c'est quoi le modèle également de la BTD
si on exporte plus d'armes parce que si
on exporte plus d'armes par définition
ça coûte plus cher donc au fond pour la
France insoumise quel serait le bon
budget idéal pour nos armées ça je pense
aussi que c'est un bon débat ça nous
permettra de comprendre aussi vos
orientations à la matière merci monsieur
le ministre pour le groupe les
républicains la parole est à Jean-Louis
thierio merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre vous nous annoncez
une hausse au titre de la LPM de 100
milliards d'euros c'est évidemment une
somme considérable cela dit l'impression
que certains ressentent c'est que malgré
une impressionnante augmentation de
budget il n'y a pas corrélativement une
augmentation de masse
je prends notamment l'exemple des
objectifs cibles les Griffons qui
passent de 1800 à
1300 à titre d'objectifs cible ou pour
la marine les frégates de défense et
d'intervention qui devait être à 5 et
qui seront à deux en fin de LPM donc ce
différentiel entre l'effort annoncé et
le résultat obtenu interroge alors il y
a l'effet de l'inflation qui part des
finitions expliquent un certain nombre
d'éléments il y a probablement
l'apparition de nouveaux champs de
conflictualité qui fait qu'on choisit
d'autres priorités mais nous serions
intéressés de comprendre cet apparent
paradoxe qui effectivement interroge
deuxième question nous avons évoqué les
marges vous y avez largement répondu je
voudrais quand même avoir votre lecture
sur la part du différentiel de marche
entre les premières années et les
suivantes de ce qui est lié directement
à la soutenabilité de la trajectoire
budgétaire et de ce qui est lié à la
BITD à sa capacité à produire et au
timing prévisionnel des programmes à
effet majeurs enfin dernière élément qui
effectivement nous interroge je vous
avais déjà interrogé sur le sujet mais
j'y reviens c'est celui des Rex et des
13 milliards de ressources extra
budgétaires comment avez-vous envisagé
leur lissage dans la durée de la LPM
est-ce qu'il y a déjà un lissage qui est
fait des prospectives précises et si par
hasard on ne les a pas que prévoyez-vous
de faire
merci beaucoup la question sur
augmentation de budget augmentation de
masse c'est une question qui est
absolument clé parce que on rentre dans
le détail désormais de ce qu'on attend
notre modèle d'armée
et donc ça pose aussi la question de
l'intran technologique
y compris pour l'avenir faites la
réalité c'est quoi quand on parle de
spatial ou de cyber on est en train de
poser des parpains qui vont servir de
fondation aussi pour les LPM qui
suivront bon donc vous avez dans ces
crédits des crédits qui sont qui vont
être consommés rapidement pour des
effets immédiats c'est vrai par exemple
pour le renseignement tu devais donner
un exemple bien précis c'est assez vrai
pour certaines recomplétuces de certains
stocks de munitions la munition non
complexe moins vrai déjà de la munition
complexe et puis vous allez avoir des
crédits de paiement pour des effets donc
vous ne verrez rien pendant cette LPM
mais ça on le sait tous c'est la même
chose à chaque fois exemple plus visible
plus évident le futur porte-avions
nouvelle génération où il est évident
que c'est de la construction et donc ça
n'aura pas d'effets militaires immédiat
ce qui d'ailleurs permet de revenir
aussi sur l'affaire des marches si les
marches sont plus importantes aussi sur
la dernière partie c'est tout simplement
parce qu'il y a un besoin de crédit de
paiement qui est plus important de la
dernière partie y compris sur la
dissuasion nucléaire modernisation de
missiles pour donner un exemple on est
sur une audition qui est retransmise
mais
pour donner un exemple très précis les
gros besoins financiers budgétaires pour
la modernisation des missiles de la
composante océanique mais encore plus
peut-être de la composante aéroportée se
fera en fin de période mais pas par
choix budgétaire parce que c'est tout
simplement la vie du programme de la
direction des applications militaires
alors après on pourrait toujours faire
un amendement pour dire qu'il faut que
ça aille plus vite mais enfin ça ça vous
verrez ça et vin chez eux Salvetti la
réalité c'est que il y a des réalités
qui tiennent à la vie des programmes ça
c'est la réalité du physique et c'est le
point du physique sur sur les marches
c'est comme ça
après un peu plus je pense qu'on peut
rentrer dans le détail si vous le
souhaitez mais évidemment c'est c'est
important sur les ressources extra
budgétaires pour le coup oui elles sont
elles sont détaillées en chronique je
vous rappelle qu'elles comprennent
plusieurs plusieurs aspects un les
ressources du service de santé des
armées je vous l'ai déjà dit mais c'est
important parce que tout simplement il y
a de la tarification
à l'acte donc là pour le coup vous avez
sur la période globalement
1,2 milliards plus 1,8 milliards pour le
sol service de santé des armées vous
avez des prestations de service la DGA
facture des choses à nous industriels
tout ça c'est de l'argent réel c'est
vraiment de la levée de ressources donc
là aussi parfois j'ai lu des choses un
peu étonnantes mais vous vous êtes
parlementaire donc vous connaissez bien
les questions budgétaires liées au
fonctionnement de l'État c'est pas de
l'argent virtuel c'est de l'argent qui
n'est pas branché directement sur la
ressource extra budget enfin sur la
ressource budgétaire c'est directement
ce que le ministère génère en ressources
ça évidemment c'est important session de
matériel et de prestation de service on
est globalement sur 652 millions d'euros
pour la période session de matériel et
formation associée dans le cadre de nos
différents programmes de coopération
c'est un milliard d'euros sur la période
le casse immobilier parce qu'on dit
beaucoup oui ça va être parce que on va
vendre du foncier arrêtez c'est que oui
quand d'autres pouvoirs fermaient des
bases et des et des régiments
effectivement beaucoup de choses à
vendre je vais vous dire qu'il y a plus
grand chose à vendre désormais donc sur
le cas immobilier on est seulement sur
une estimation à 474 millions d'euros et
après il y a des dividendes d'un certain
nombre de contrats qu'on est en train de
renégocier ou qui ont été renégociés
donc certains sont un peu discrets mais
pour 650 millions d'euros donc là vous
avez 5,8 milliards d'euros sur les
seules ressources extra budgétaires pour
24 30 ensuite j'ai la chronique par
année typiquement 2024 le total de cette
affaire c'est un milliard 300 en 2025
c'est un milliard 48 pour des raisons
qui tiennent à certaines lignes en 2026
et 898 millions 2027 693 millions 2028
648 millions 2029 629 millions 2030 628
millions se présente que monsieur le
rapporteur ce que je vous propose c'est
que ce tableau on a rien à cacher c'est
qu'on le communique à l'ensemble des
commissaires pour vous permettre de voir
comment la chronique est faite et qui
montre aussi le sérieux de ce qui a été
fait par la direction des affaires
financières du ministère merci monsieur
le ministre pour le groupe démocrate la
parole est à Jean-Pierre cubertaffond
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre cher collègue nous en parlions
depuis des mois voilà enfin venu le
temps de commencer le travail
parlementaire sur cette nouvelle loi de
programmation militaire pour la période
2024 2030 le budget présenté est
important mais il est à la hauteur de
l'ambition affichée faire de la France
une nation capable de s'impliquer dans
un conflit de haute intensité mais aussi
de défendre ses intérêts et son
territoire métropolitain comme
ultramarin pour tous ces éléments
monsieur le ministre vous pourrez
compter sur le soutien de notre groupe
démocrate qui se réjouit de la vision à
long terme proposée pour nos armées dans
un monde où les tensions deviennent de
plus en plus importantes et les
conflictualités incertaine
nos concitoyens s'apprêtent à consentir
un effort budgétaire conséquent pour
notre appareil de défense et il apparaît
plus que jamais nécessaire de pouvoir
aujourd'hui bien expliqué la nécessité
de cet effort au-delà de la pédagogie
nous devons consacrer dans cette LPM la
nécessité de recréer du lien entre
l'armée et la population alors que les
casernes et les industrielles ne sont
plus aussi présents sur nos territoires
que par le passé monsieur le ministre
vous présenter un budget qui par rapport
à 2017 conduira la France à doubler ses
dépenses militaires d'ici à 2030 et ce
dans la perspective de préparer un
potentiel retour de conflits de haute
intensité dans la complexité apparente
des tensions de demain comment Monsieur
le Ministre peut-on recréer un lien
particulier qui unira l'armée et la
nation
la guerre en Ukraine nous porte à la
réflexion mais ce qui impactera
fortement notre modèle et la nécessité
de nous transformer en économie de
guerre sentez-vous chez nos partenaires
européens notamment à travers d'achat
mutualisé une volonté de partager cet
effort monsieur le ministre je vous
remercie
merci aussi pour l'accompagnement pour
Bergerac et pour la localisation de
Rinko puisque une fois de plus c'est un
exemple concret de ce que nous
souhaitons faire sur l'économie de
guerre pour répondre aussi à votre
question donc je pense que l'Europe de
la défense est un sujet dont on parle
peu
je considère qu'elle a une crédibilité
et une réalité c'est bien sur les effets
de marché et sur les relocalisations
dans l'espace européen le
covid c'est voir malheureusement des des
dépendances hors Union Européenne d'un
certain nombre de filières
d'approvisionnement en matière première
qui est tout à fait préoccupante donc là
l'Europe a évidemment un rôle à jouer la
capacité à acheter en commun est aussi
évidemment quelque chose de absolument
clé et ça je ressens une volonté je veux
saluer le travail du commissaire breton
d'ailleurs en la matière puisque ça nous
permet quand même d'avoir aussi
désormais un dialogue à plusieurs et
aussi tout simplement de négocier des
prix ou d'organiser aussi au mieux les
choses pour la véritéde et donc ça je le
parmi nous nos partenaires une volonté
de une volonté de faire et ça ça me
semble concret je pense aussi qu'il faut
que on réfléchisse de plus en plus
au-delà de l'économie de guerre et c'est
un peu votre question sur la relation à
la nation a aussi la je peux pas dire la
finance de guerre en tout cas la
capacité de financer notre BITD
l'accès à certains produits bancaires
l'accès à l'épargne on a trop de PME
c'était la question du député tout à
l'heure baby sur au fond mais faut aider
nos PME le problème c'est que les PME
parfois elles ont beaucoup de mal à
trouver des produits de financement dans
le réseau bancaire ou sur la place
financière et ça on peut pas parler de
patriotisme on peut pas parler de
souveraineté d'autonomie stratégique si
en même temps que l'économie de guerre
c'était le côté production on n'a pas
aussi un accès aux financement et ça
c'est évidemment un sujet clé l'Europe
de nous y aider compris sur les sujets
taxonomie etc qui sont des sujets
importants voilà en synthèse pour
répondre à votre question après la
question comment rapprocher la nation de
son armée et l'armée de sa nation en 2
minutes c'est pratiquement un beau sujet
de coloc monsieur député merci monsieur
monsieur ministre pour le groupe
socialiste la parole est à anapick
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre cette future LPM est souvent
évoquée à travers ses 413 milliards
d'euros mais ne doit pas cacher selon
nous un point essentiel à savoir que ce
montant ne peut être réalisé qu'au nom
de futurs arbitrages deuxièmement ce
montant comprend également un report de
charge de 100 milliards d'euros
provenant de la LPM actuelle et qu'il
reste à clarifier enfin nous savons
également que très souvent les budgets
prévus ne pourront être respectés
notamment pour les seules opérations
extérieures qui sont régulièrement sous
budgété puis réajuster concrètement si
nous seulions l'augmentation des budgets
les temps désormais de clarifier à la
fois les moyens de nos dépenses et de
savoir pourquoi l'on dépense vous avez
évoqué aujourd'hui les grandes lignes
que nous creuserons plus avant dans les
prochains jours et prochaines semaines
aussi si nous ne pouvons alors actuelle
anticiper quel ministère vont connaître
des baisses pour compenser la hausse
apportant du budget de la défense et il
m'imagine bien que l'éducation et les
affaires sociales sont pour votre
gouvernement comme pour nous une
priorité que nous partageons nous serons
attentifs à ce que le discours et les
analyses qui entourent la construction
de cet LPM n'autorise pas pour autant à
renier sur les enjeux qui font le
quotidien de nos concitoyens nous
appelons aussi à ce que les dépenses de
défense ne se fassent pas sans regarder
nos partenaires européens dépenser sans
s'intéresser à l'Union européenne qui
représente la deuxième puissance
militaire en termes de dépenses serait
une impasse pour la défense de la zone
dans le contexte que nous connaissons
une autre interrogation
subsiste à propos de l'accélération
prévue à partir de 2027 mais vous l'avez
dit la LPM est soumise aux aléas
politiques internationaux et dans un
contexte inflationniste fort nous
apprécions l'engagement concernant la
clause de revoyure qui sera l'occasion
d'un débat démocratique et d'un exercice
de contrôle dans la conduite de cette
loi donc ainsi bien que satisfait de la
mise de la prise en compte d'un certain
nombre d'éléments vous l'aurez compris
nous serons vigilants quant à la
répartition qui sera faite de cette LPM
et à l'adaptation budgétaire de celle-ci
aux ambitions affichées pour nos armées
je vous remercie
beaucoup alors les report de charge sont
bien intégrés dans la copie sinon ça
veut dire que la copie que je vous
proposerai ne serait pas sincère je vous
rassure et je vois un point à votre
question ils sont évidemment bien dedans
mais vous avez raison de dire parce que
en fait on oublie trop souvent que ce
que j'ai dans mon propos introductif une
LPM ne part pas une page blanche y
compris sur le terrain budgétaire donc
vous avez des coûts partis comme on dit
si bien et que il faut déjà il vous
socle une partie de cette LPM et
d'ailleurs c'est bien naturel parce que
ça crée des effets militaires réels avec
des productions des livraisons d'armes
etc donc ça c'est évidemment un point
clé alors OPEX sous budgeté en fait ce
n'est pas arrivé que toutefois c'est
parce qu'évidemment il y a eu il y a eu
le Sahel et que en fait vous ne pouvez
pas savoir à l'avance là où vos armées
vont être employées et d'ailleurs
regardez ce qui s'est passé en 2022 où
vous avez à la fin à la fois pardon la
fin de barkhane d'une part et en même
temps la montée en puissance de
l'opération aigle sur le flanc oriental
de l'Europe de toute façon c'est je
reviens ce que j'ai sur une armée
d'emploi
part d'aléa qui est importante c'est
pour ça d'ailleurs que législateur a
imaginé quelque chose qu'elle
approvision pour les Opex donc en fait
on peut pas parler vraiment de sous
budgétisation parce que il y a une
provision soit elle est pas utilisée
d'ailleurs elle reste aux armées je vous
confirme d'ailleurs que ce dispositif
sera maintenu dans le cadre de la LPM à
soit il n'y a pas assez d'argent pardon
de le dire comme ça parce que c'est
l'activité des forces ne serait à être
tenue pour des raisons qu'on comprend
bien par le cadre budgétaire et c'est
pour ça que vous avez d'une part des
mécanismes interministériels qui peuvent
se déclencher et puis surtout et c'est
ce qu'on fait en vrai comme dirait
l'autre on fait à chaque fois si on
revient devant le Parlement au PLF et là
on s'insérer tout de suite la copie et
on permet évidemment de demander des
ouvertures de créer nouveau en tout cas
il n'y a pas de quel que soit d'ailleurs
les familles politiques les alternances
politiques sous la Cinquième République
il y a jamais eu de billets sur ce point
de vue évidemment je veux vous rassurer
pas de baisse des autres ministères pour
financer cette trajectoire mais c'est
aussi parce qu'elle est soutenable et
donc on revient aussi aux efforts mais
plus j'ai déjà répondu sur sur cette
quant à la revoyure elle est clé les
clés aussi pour des raisons
démocratiques me semble-t-il ce sont des
sommes importantes et puis je pense
aussi que c'est l'occasion aussi pour
chaque famille politique de dire un tout
petit peu aussi à de là de focus
d'argent plus vite ou il en faudrait
moins de dire aussi
[Musique]
un correctif cette année d'un milliard 5
j'y reviendrai sur une petite question
technique
et ma question générale qui nous amènera
un esprit de synthèse
est au fond sur l'ambition géopolitique
et géostratégique qui sous-tend le
modèle d'armée que vous soumettez à
notre appréciation parce que la revue
nationale stratégique nous a promenés du
Groenland à Nouméa autour d'une notion
qu'à titre personnel je trouve assez
chancelante et un peu malheureuse
d'équilibre
j'ai notamment en tête deux sujets
particuliers
la stratégie de Pacifique vous l'avez un
petit peu évoqué est-ce que c'est pas
plutôt une stratégie Indo Médor autour
du groupe aeronaval et une stratégie
plutôt pack autour de patrouilleur bon
et puis au fond la question du pivot à
l'est jusqu'au pouvons-nous aller tenant
compte de certains décalages et
réduction de cible je pense particuliers
à l'armée de terre sur lesquels je
reviendrai dans d'autres auditions donc
voilà cette question sur vraiment le
l'ambition que vous défendez et une
question technique monsieur le Président
si vous me permett ce 1 milliard cinq
encore actif budgétaire pour l'année
2023 est-ce que c'est du solde net ou
est-ce que ce sera retranché au fond des
annualités budgétaires 24 et 25 je vous
remercie pour la créativité sur le
ministre seul donuts c'est l'intérêt une
fois plus enfin j'ai pas répondu au
député la chaux mais sur les la
programmation permet la clarification
pour les armées donc je vous rassure
aussi sur ce point et après faut être
cohérent on peut pas dire d'un côté il y
a de l'inflation et c'est terrible et
puis quand on vient corriger l'inflation
en disant bah c'est terrible parce que
vous rajoutez de l'argent qui correspond
plus aux marches
faut faire la mise en cohérence de notre
affaire donc oui le meilleur 5 permet de
traiter l'inflation permet de traiter un
sens de choses en net et ne vient pas
être retranché des annuités qui
viendront et donc c'est un plancher sur
la question de passionnante sur la
géopolitique pour le coup
si on découpe les choses en morceaux et
en 2 minutes c'est quasiment imposable
mais la question du flan oriental de
l'Europe il faudra quand même se poser
la question de la durabilité de de ça
qu'en fait ça a du sens d'être nationale
quand l'armée partenaire du pays haute
engage sa montée en puissance c'est la
discussion que j'ai avec les autorités
roumaines en ce moment comme vous le
savez il y a des discussions aussi sur
des prospects d'un certain nombre de
programmes d'armement des entraînements
qui sont en commun bon on a que là il
est clair que les affaires de nationales
c'est un moyen aussi pour tout le monde
de monter en puissance et aussi
d'ailleurs pour les nôtres de militaires
de s'entraîner mais ça
effectivement ça c'est pas un OPEX comme
les autres parce que précisément il y a
pas de combat il y a pas d'ouverture au
feu
heureusement
mais ça c'est absolument clé non un dos
Pacifique je pense que en 30 secondes si
je devais résumer les choses mais ça
mériterait à mon avis de détailler les
choses parce que ça dit quelque chose du
tableau capacité c'est pour ça je les
marches tout ça c'est bien mais enfin au
bout d'un moment faut repartir aussi
comme des missions ça parfois les uns
des autres sont un peu moins sonore sur
ce sujet un peu moins vocal en portant
c'est absolument clé je pense qu'au fond
sur l'Indo on a véritablement un enjeu
de coalition de force prépositionner
Djibouti H5 et Jordanie et évidemment la
base que nous avons Emirats Arabes Unis
avec des capacités de tenir des libertés
y compris des libertés d'accès
ciel un peu maritime énormément
sécurisation de la façon de l'espace
pourraient développer qui englobe
évidemment Mayotte et la Réunion donc là
je pense qu'on a une famille de sujets
très interarmée très intérieure et puis
dans le pack c'est plutôt pacsud déjà la
dominante et là faut avoir une une
réflexion de riverain tout simplement
c'est-à-dire en clair on n'est pas sur
l'expéditionnaire on est véritablement à
domicile et dans une capacité alors une
fois plus pour être détailler tout ça ça
veut dire que dans un cas c'est des
moyens pour emmener des autres dans
l'autre cas c'est des moyens plutôt pour
faire seul sur une zone plus à nous si
je devais dire les choses de manière
très schématique en tout cas vous avez
raison la copie le PM et je me forcerai
de le faire dans l'hémicyclotant qu'il
le faudra elle se connecte aux missions
à notre diplomatie au delà des marches
et des milliards merci monsieur le
ministre pour le groupe écologiste la
parole est à Julien Bayou
oui merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Ministre merci pour votre
présentation je vais pas parler des
chiffres avec trop peu de temps mais je
suis des orientations parce que je suis
surpris que personne les interroge
fondamentalement deux points en 2
minutes c'est pas évident mais donc
premier point la dissuasion nucléaire
quasiment la moitié des dépenses en fait
est aspiré par le renouvellement de la
dissuasion nucléaire si on ajoute la
modernisation des armes des vecteurs et
des porteurs on a déjà eu la discussion
mais outre les aspects éthiques qu'on
peut pas balayer mais qu'on peut pas
aborder en 30 secondes
la dissuasion suppose la rationalité
l'adversaire qui veut pas tout perdre et
c'est un calcul des fois hasardeux quand
on est en face un groupe terroriste ou
un état terroriste au hasard l'Iran dans
ce cas là vous avez la dépense et vous
avez quand même le risque de frappe
parce que lui ne partage pas votre
rationalité ou votre doctrine le général
pétraus général américain disait que la
dissuasion pouvait être plus efficace
par la capacité du conventionnelle en
légitime défense plus pragmatique plus
efficace
autre aspect et en une minute
autregageur la question du porte-avion
remplaçant du Charles de Gaulle il y
aura eu aucun débat public sur des
dépenses qui vont engager le pays pour
des décennies pas de débat la France
doit avoir son porte-avion moi j'y vois
une politique du prestige en décalage en
fait avec les capacités budgétaires du
pays et en décalage avec les besoins
géopolitiques si on a un seul
porte-avions
ça permet pas la permanence à la mer on
est plutôt sur 50% de disponibilités
et pourtant ça coûte cher il faut
ajouter évidemment la flotte des scores
et de logistique est-ce qu'on peut
parler d'une ligne Maginot de la mer si
on voulait provocateur et ne pensez-vous
pas qu'on puisse faire plus concret plus
utile plus adapté
notamment sur la question la
responsabilité de la France sur le
domaine maritime menacé par le
changement climatique les catastrophes
naturelles les pollutions la surpêche
est-ce que vous envoyez un porte-avion
véritablement lutter contre la surpêche
est-ce qu'on pourrait pas plutôt avec le
budget économisé et j'en termine
monsieur Président on pourrait imaginer
un quatrième portée hélicoptère amphibie
une douzaine de patriotes patrouilleur
océanique renforcement de la flotte
d'avion l'équipement drone et les
hélicoptères voyez que ça libérait des
capacités monsieur le ministre merci
monsieur le député Bayou bon dissuasion
en peu de temps sur une édition
retransmise pour un désarmée c'est
quasiment impossible en tout cas alors
c'est pas la moitié rassurez-vous
vraiment l'agrégat dissuasion à peu près
représentera en pourcentage la même
chose que la LPM précédente entre les
lignes on comprend donc que ça augmente
quand même pour des raisons évidentes
que je pourrais peut-être détailler dans
un autre format après sur la rationalité
de l'adversaire etc moi je basique comme
dirait l'autre ce que je vois c'est
qu'aujourd'hui cette dissuasion est
toujours utile ça j'ai pas de doute et
ceux qui se passe avec la Fédération de
Russie tant à le démontrer hélas si
j'ose dire une fois plus dans un autre
cadre peut-être monsieur le Président si
vous le souhaitez hors retransmission on
pourra peut-être traiter de ce sujet qui
me semble important en tout cas moi je
ne refuse pas je vais le dire comme ça
je ne refuse aucun débat sur la
diffusion nucléaire parce que je
considère que
c'est une démocratie et que le général
de Gaulle a souhaité l'élection du
Président de la République au suffrage
universel direct parce qu'il y avait la
force de frappe il a souhaité un débat
au Parlement qui dure c'était pas bien
passé y compris au Sénat parce qu'il y
avait la force de frappe et je pense que
faire comme si c'est toujours consensuel
c'est une erreur démocratiquement moi je
suis très militant de la dissuasion je
suis très favorable à disposition
nucléaire et donc je pense que c'est
bien que dans la commission de la
défense peut-être dans un format plus
discret on peut savoir les discussions
sur ce sujet là en tout cas c'est
l'honneur de notre démocratie que de le
faire sur le porte-avion c'est pareil
alors de fait il y aura un débat
monsieur le député parce que votre droit
d'amendement fait que vous pouvez très
bien mettre un coup de cutter sur le
rapport annexé et faire disparaître la
ligne du porte-avion de nouvelle
génération vous aurez du mal à faire
disparaître le porte-avion Charles de
Gaulle parce que lui il est bel et bien
là physiquement en tout cas vous avez le
droit d'interroger et d'ailleurs je
trouve que c'est plutôt astucieux de
votre part de de porter la question
comme vous l'avez fait total des accord
avec ce que vous avez dit mais néanmoins
la question existe et on va pas se
raconter d'histoires elle existe aussi
au sein des états majors pas faire de
langue de bois avec vous
pas trop dans les états major de la
marine ça c'est vrai mais en tout cas
dans les tas majeurs des autres armées
c'est quand même évidemment quelque
chose qui existe et en disant mais au
fond est-ce qu'en 2040 2045 on n'ira pas
vers un tout drôle donc est-ce que faut
encore avoir un porte aéronef est-ce que
au fond la propulsion nucléaire il faut
absolument la garder pour les zones dans
lesquelles on veut l'employer est-ce que
au fond un porte-avion comme celui-ci
dans quelle mesure il n'est pas plus
vulnérable il nous expose qu'autre chose
est-ce que la famille encore un avenir
ce ne sont pas des questions médiocres
et moi je souhaite autant que faire ce
peu pouvoir répondre à vos questions sur
ces sujets je pense qu'il y a de la
place pour un porte-avion un peu pour ce
que je disais tout à l'heure sur la
géopolitique sur les libertés d'accès
maritimes hormous Babel Mendel Suez la
dureté que représente les enjeux de
sécurité en mer Méditerranée demain
parce que Wagner en parce que des bases
russes qui avec une sous-marinade russe
qui reste très agressive y compris
d'ailleurs au large de la Bretagne donc
j'ai pas le temps de tout détailler en
tout cas je pense qu'il y a enfin je ne
l'aurais pas proposé si on n'était pas
convaincu je pense qu'il y a de la place
pour un nouveau porte-avion mais merci
parlez des choix militaires parce que je
vois la passion qu'on a pour la gestion
de l'inflation je note qui est beaucoup
de gens qui peuvent être directeurs les
affaires financières du ministère des
armées si on avait besoin mais au fond
le vrai débat politique il est à ce
niveau là et ça je pense qu'il faut
l'avoir parce que sinon nos concitoyens
ne comprendront pas les orientations que
la nation veut prendre que les
représentants de la nation veulent
prendre sur notre appareil militaire
voilà et la diffusion nucléaire de
toutes les évidences elle n'est pas
consensuelle dans le pays j'en suis un
des plus grands militants et je vois
bien qu'elle est pas consensuelle donc
faut en parler merci monsieur le
ministre et je me permets de rappeler
également que la Commission de la
Défense organisée un cycle complet sur
la dissuasion nucléaire au mois de
janvier enfin pour le groupe yote la
parole est à Christophe negelen
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues 413
milliards jusqu'en 2030 chacun peut ici
ou pourrait en tout cas ici se féliciter
de la hausse des crédits et monsieur le
ministre sans relativiser vos efforts
d'arbitrage budgétaire j'imagine qu'ils
ont dû être extrêmement serrés il faut
prendre en compte une inflation record
que nous connaissons tous et doit nous
amener donc à limiter en fin de compte
notre enthousiasme néanmoins trois
questions tout d'abord sur le rôle du
Parlement notre groupe n'a cessé de le
rappeler il faut renforcer la place des
députés des sénateurs dans la conception
de notre stratégie militaire et dans le
contrôle de l'action du ministère cet
LPM doit être l'occasion pour le
Parlement de se réapproprier la
déforestational c'est la ligne que nous
préconisons c'est la ligne qu'il faut
suivre une question très simple allez
vous garantir le principe d'une
véritable actualisation législative ami
parcours ces ajustements sont essentiels
en 2018
personne n'aurait pu anticiper ni la
pandémie ni l'Ukraine ni l'inflation
sous la précédente législature la LPM
n'avait pas été réellement respectée le
gouvernement s'étend limité un débat
suivi d'un vote il faut faire évoluer
les dispositions à ce niveau que
proposez-vous concrètement second point
le service national universel le salut
nous sommes dans une situation qui est
relativement paradoxale d'un côté nous
avons une expérimentation qui a connu un
certain succès auprès de nos jeunes et
de l'autre on retire ce sujet de l'ordre
du jour monsieur le ministre vous savez
très bien qu'un des défis de votre
ministère reste l'attractivité auprès
des jeunes et la fidélisation des
personnels donc concrètement pouvez-vous
nous éclairer où en sont les travaux de
votre ministère sur le SNU un dernier
point sur l'outre-mer que j'aborderai
très brièvement et je laisserai ma
collègue Estelle Youssoupha vous en
parlez et nous avons tout à l'heure eu
le rapporteur qui a qui a exprimé des
questions sur les autres mères il nous
faut impérativement une trajectoire pour
les forces de souveraineté stationner
dans les territoires ultramarins comment
vont se déployer ces nouveaux
investissements et quelle répartition
parmi nos collectivités
ultramarines c'est une question de
souveraineté de protection d'intégrité
de nos territoires et d'appui pour la
protection locale monsieur le ministre
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Président et jeune alors sur les trois
questions juste déjà un chapeau bon
l'inflation vous l'avez redit enfin je
pense aussi que la manière dont on
traite enfin la question de
l'acceptabilité politique et sociétale
des dépenses militaires passe aussi
quand même par la démonstration que on
fait très attention à l'argent public en
la matière je le redis parce qu'on ne le
dit plus et donc faut faire attention à
ça sur les trois questions
outre-mer j'ai eu l'occasion déjà de le
développer mais si même Youssoupha me
pose une question peut-être que je je
ferai un petit focus plus particulier
sur Mayotte au hasard pour pour
évidemment répondre je tiendrai à votre
disposition de toute façon je réunirai
les différentes parlementaires
d'outre-mer pour traiter de cette
question là et je le disais tout à
l'heure moi je crois beaucoup à
l'intrant technologique je veux dire on
parle des usages spatiaux ou drone s'il
y a bien un endroit dans lequel ça peut
avoir beaucoup de prix c'est bel et bien
en outre-mer donc on y reviendra mais ça
c'est un point important bon rôle du
Parlement pour moi c'est clé je le dis
je l'ai commencé mon propos introductif
là dessus ça me permet de vous confirmer
ce que je vous ai dit tout à l'heure
on a repris dans le projet de loi
évidemment un article amélioré de ce qui
existait et de ce que le Parlement avait
souhaité intégrer dans la précédente
programmation militaire et j'ai écrit à
Yaël privé Gérard Larcher au président
Cambon et au président gassiou pour leur
dire que moi j'étais complètement
disponible pour trouver une écriture
qu'il vous va dans la manière de générer
les réactualisations moi je souhaite
qu'il y en ait une avant la prochaine
élection présidentielle ça me semble clé
je précise tout de suite que ça ne meurt
pas de toute façon ce que le Parlement a
fait un nouveau Parlement peut le
défaire donc il y a pas de compétences
liées et donc un nouveau pouvoir peut
très bien décider de tout changer
politique et je souhaite même au regard
de la situation stratégique qu'on puisse
avoir une véritable réactualisation
annuelle alors vous allez me dire enfin
on le fait déjà avec le web finance
c'est vrai sauf que dans les lots de
finances c'est que très compliqué
parfois de s'y retrouver pour tels que
les textes financiers sont présentés
budgétaires et financiers et donc au
fond nous le ministère fait chaque année
développer une a2pm une mise à jour en
gestion pour le ministère de l'exécution
de cette programmation militaire et moi
ce que je vous propose les proposer au
président c'est d'avoir justement cette
actualisation annuelle et au fait qui va
d'ailleurs relativiser les affaires de
marche parce que en fait à chaque fois
vous allez voir que des programmes
prennent de l'avance d'autres prennent
du retard que parfois vous avez une
bonne nouvelle d'exportation qui fait
que ça chamboule complètement le rythme
de production par exemple des frais gaz
à Lorient au hasard parce que on
souhaite de bonnes nouvelles sur cette
affaire à l'avenir donc je pense que ça
va et moi je suis honnête avec vous ça
me permet aussi de mieux associer le
Parlement mais de mieux partager la
contrainte réelle du monde réel avec le
parlementaire ça évite aussi le Yaka
faucon parfois que j'entends jamais ici
mais enfin qui pourrait parfois quand
même prendre le bout de son nez et c'est
nul alors le SCI n'est pas dans la
programmation militaire ça ne veut pas
dire qu'il n'est pas toujours parmi les
priorités du gouvernement il n'est pas
dans la programmation militaire aussi
puisque nous sommes un peu pur
programmation militaire c'est fait pour
le format des armées c'est nul pas
vocation à participer au format des
armées après que des jeunes ayant fait
leur SNU et des envies d'intégrer les
armées de devenir réserviste ça on le
souhaite tous j'imagine que les
militaires puissent apporter leur
contribution au sneu ça aussi mais le
format des armées c'est le format des
armées voilà ça c'est un état auprès du
musée éducation nationale et de votre
serviteur continue à travailler sur les
options de généralisation et d'ailleurs
j'ai indiqué aux prisons des Sioux que
ça pourrait avoir du sens que vous le
disiez et qu'elle vous dise parce que au
fond les armées contribuent à la marge
au projet SNU c'est aussi des autres
administrations dont l'éducation
nationale qui sont aussi évidemment
première à fonctionner à marcher sur sur
la programmation militaire voilà en
quelques mots monsieur le Président pour
vous répondre merci monsieur le ministre
nous avons ici terminé avec les
interventions des orateurs de groupe il
nous reste 24 questions qui sont rappels
la limiter à une minute la parole est à
Christophe Lassard
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre bonjour suite au rapport que
j'ai publié vendredi on constate une
BITD qui fonctionne essentiellement sur
la base du bon de commande et vous
l'avez signalé tout à l'heure le
changement de paradigme est nécessaire
chez les industriels qui sont désormais
enfin qui ont désormais une visibilité
pour développer innover exporter sur la
base de la confiance et de ce marché
malheureusement dynamique mais reste
l'accès des PME assez assez commande
leur capacité à devenir des ETI
également l'une des pistes est l'accès à
la commande directe dans les unités
d'objets en face de développement
d'expérimentation ou issus du civil cet
accès direct preuve d'agilité de
réactivité et d'adaptabilité est-elle
vraiment à l'ordre du jour et aussi
surtout dirais-je l'accompagnement de
l'accès aux financement de ces
entreprises merci
merci non on va tout prendre ensemble la
parole est à Olivier Marex
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre le grand paradoxe de cette LPM
c'est l'annonce d'un investissement
record mais de reports de livraison ou
des baisses de cible d'acquisition par
rapport à l'alpm 2019 malgré le retour
de la guerre en Europe quelques exemples
là où la présentat LPM ciblait 185
rafales prévues en 2030 on est plus qu'à
137 on sera donc loin du Tour rafale
avec 48 rafales de chute 5 frégates de
défense et d'intervention en 2030 était
prévue on ne saura plus qu'à 3 et là où
on avait 50 avions de transport à 400 m
le cible désormais 2030 sera plus que 35
donc si on ne peut évidemment
qu'apprécier la cible de la trajectoire
on ne peut pas s'empêcher d'avoir le
sentiment quand même que cette LPM
souffre de d'arbitrage contenu de l'état
de nos finances publiques d'arbitrage
négatif pour 2024 2025 où il aurait
fallu sans doute concentrer le moyen
pour répondre à la menace merci la
parole est à franginetti
oui merci monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre après la tyrannie la
distance est tyrannie du temps pour les
questions mais
allons directement vous avez visiblement
du lutter contre Matignon qui a œuvré
pour que cette LPM soit seulement de 392
milliards d'euros dans cette lignée on
apprend que sans son cher 49-3 la
première ministre entend désormais
compliqué la tâche des armées en
s'attaquant à la hauteur des marches à
savoir la gradation annuelle des crédits
budgétaires madame borne ne craint pas
de ce de trébucher dans les escaliers en
effet dans la perspective d'une économie
de guerre mais aussi face aux besoins
éminent de réellement de la France
militaire et industriel ne cesse
d'alerter quant à la nécessité de
rehausser le budget dès les premières
marches à savoir dès 2024 suggérant une
hausse annuelle de 5 milliards d'euros
du reste on en est pas très loin parce
que les 3 milliards plus 1,5 milliards
de pelle fr on c'est cela est tout à
fait réalisable monsieur le ministre
parti un pas de savoir si cela émane du
ministre du ministère des armées ou de
la première ministre nous ne pouvons que
constater regretter que ces premières
marches avec le niveau d'inflation que
nous connaissons soit largement
inférieur aux besoins de nos armées Doom
mccins le cadencement prévu et la part
dédié de ces marches à l'activité des
équipages de l'Armée de l'Air
permettront-ils de garantir année après
année un socle d'activités satisfaisant
merci merci la parole est à Aurélien
sans Toul la
merci merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre
vous parlez de marche qui ne sont
déclenchées et non pas des plafonds je
vous suggère de désormais de faire une
loi de programmation à base de
fourchette comme ça on aura des chiffres
crédibles vous parliez de pouvoir qui
permet des bases je signale le
respectueusement que nous n'étions pas
responsables de ces fermetures de base
la plupart d'entre vous peut-être
soutenaient la politique de du président
Sarkozy et j'entre avec des questions
précises vous avez évoqué le s&u vous
dites que c'est à la marge une politique
portée par le minable il est cité deux
fois dans le rapport annexé et ça
généralisation estimée à un coût de 3
milliards on a du mal à imaginer que si
elle devait être avoir lieu pendant le
temps de la LPM elle n'affecterait pas
la programmation donc j'aimerais avoir
un éclairage là dessus j'aimerais parler
du SSA vous avez donné les grandes
lignes mais j'aimerais savoir si les
établissements qui sont menacés de
fermeture vont effectivement fermer vous
m'aviez promis que les transformations
étaient suspendues en hémicycle ça
n'était pas le cas et puis j'aimerais
avoir quelques précisions sur vos
projets sur la maîtrise des fonds marins
vous savez que le sujet m'intéresse
merci la parole est à Vincent Bru
merci monsieur le président pendant que
nous scrutons la Garonne en Europe au
Levant et en Afrique la menace perdure
les orientations de la LPM rappelle
d'ailleurs que la menace djihadiste
demeure et la France et reste une cible
le conflit asymétrique nécessite
l'action de nos forces spéciales en lien
étroit avec les forces conventionnelles
les 2 milliards d'euros proposés dans un
investissement dans la loi de
programmation militaire pour nos forces
spéciales promettent une montée en
puissance technologique et humaine la
question pour l'utilisation des crédits
comptez-vous élargir le spectre humain
des forces spéciales en augmentant les
effectifs et pouvez-vous nous préciser
vos orientations sur les investissements
dans les moyens d'action de surface et
sous-marine de nouvelles générations je
vous remercie merci la parole est à
Yannick Favennec
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre notre autonomie stratégique
s'inscrit dans un cadre national mais
nous avons également l'ambition d'une
autonomie stratégique de l'Europe et la
France poursuit son investissement dans
le volley strictement européen de la
défense en outre les moyens alloués à
notre défense sont quasiment tous
employables dans un cadre national mais
également dans un cadre européen à cet
égard dans un contexte de solidarité de
mutualisation de nos capacités je
voudrais vous questionner plus
particulièrement sur la coopération
autour de l'Atlas A400M d'Airbus le
rapport annexé du projet de loi de
programmation militaire fixe les
prévisions du parc de A400M à plus de 35
pour 2030 l'objectif final étant
initialement fixé aux alentours de 50 je
m'interroge sur les éventuels
conséquences sur le déficit des
capacités européennes en matière de
transport aérien et souhaiterait avoir
votre point de vue sur ce sujet je vous
remercie merci la parole est à Alexandra
Martin merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre je souhaite revenir
sur le service national universelle qui
était une promesse de campagne
d'Emmanuel Macron vous l'avez dit ce
dispositif a été retiré de la loi de
programmation militaire alors si nous
pouvons comprendre le critère budgétaire
qui a présidé à cette prise de décision
nous regrettons l'absence de perspective
d'alternative alors une autre société
est fracturée archipelisé ou la violence
de biomniprésente la conception même de
la citoyenneté devient une approche
abstraite pour la jeune génération et il
nous sent plus urgent de tout mettre en
oeuvre pour inverser ce mouvement alors
de nombreux outils existent mais ils
sont tous basés sur le volontariat la
généralisation des enseignements compris
dans le SAU avec un retour aux
enseignements approfondis de la
citoyenneté au cours du parcours
scolaire au collège tel que nous le
préconisons permettrait de retisser le
lien aujourd'hui distendu entre les
jeunes et la nation française monsieur
le ministre notre devoir n'est-il pas de
créer les conditions d'un nouvel élan
citoyen qui permettra à notre jeunesse
de renouer avec le sentiment
d'appartenance à la Nation pour en faire
des citoyens engagés éclairés
responsables et de nourrir la résilience
de la société n'est-ce pas là l'esprit
de la défense merci la parole est à
Martin
pardon merci merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre le ministère des
armées ce sont des personnes militaires
et civiles qui peuvent comme dans
n'importe quel autre secteur faire face
à des discriminations ou des violences
sur leur lieu de travail l'amélioration
des conditions de vie et de travail des
militaires et des civils de la défense
fait partie intégrante des objectifs de
la LPM pourtant rien n'est annoncé
spécifiquement dans le projet de loi ce
qui concerne la lutte contre les
discriminations et les violences au sein
des armées les discriminations les
violences commises par un collègue ou un
supérieur c'est aussi ça une armée qui
dysfonctionne avec des conséquences sur
les parcours de vie et de carrière ou
encore sur l'attractivité des métiers de
la défense c'est pourquoi je voudrais
vous interroger sur le budget à louer au
dispositif dans ces dotés le ministère
pour lutter contre les discriminations
et contre les violences et en
particulier la cellule Thémis créée il y
a 9 ans pour lutter contre le
harcèlement sexuel les VSS et les
discriminations pourriez-vous nous
indiquer quel budget est alloué à ce
dispositif quelle est l'évolution prévue
de ce budget dans les années à venir et
si vous comptez donner à la cellulite
les moyens nécessaires à son bon
fonctionnement merci merci la parole est
à Julien en cool
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre la France a un défi majeur
amené pour renforcer et structurer
davantage sa filière drone c'est
essentiel si on veut avoir des champions
français suffisamment puissants pour
aller gagner des gros marchés en France
et à l'étranger selon une étude de
levitate capital excusé mon accent de
décembre 2020 les perspectives de marché
de la filière drone vont exploser dans
la décennie à venir au niveau mondial
avec 34 milliards de dollars de
potentiels économiques les États-Unis
représenteront le plus gros marché en
2030 devant l'Asie 30 milliards et
l'Europe 16 milliards il ne faudrait pas
que la France rate ce virage du drone 5
milliards d'euros devrait être débloqués
pour les drones entre 2020 et 2024 et
2030 dans la loi de programmation
militaire monsieur le ministre
pouvez-vous nous dire comment faire en
sorte que ces 5 milliards nous
permettent de un renforcement et une
structuration de notre filière
industrielle française de drone au-delà
même de l'augmentation de notre capacité
opérationnelle dans le domaine je vous
remercie merci la parole est à Mélanie
Thomas merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre vous avez dit tout
à l'heure vous tenir à la disposition du
Parlement je vous en remercie parce que
dans le contexte politique et social
actuel pour mener à bien nos travaux et
nos débats pour cette loi de
programmation militaire les Français ont
plus que besoin de leur parlement et de
leur avis
je voulais revenir sur le contexte
stratégique celui-là même qui nous
impose de marquer une tragique une
trajectoire claire d'investissement dans
notre défense et puis réagir également
au contexte inflationniste tout à
l'heure vous avez eu l'occasion de
rappeler que dans les budgets publics
des collectivités
et bien nous faisons face à une certaine
inflation et cette préoccupation de
l'inflation n'est pas une fantaisie de
la part de la plupart des parlementaires
qui sont ici réunis et je voulais je
voulais le rappeler c'est une réalité
concrète pour nos budgets publics une
question
sur l'ensemble des crédits environ 60%
semble devoir être dévoluer au
renouvellement de la dissuasion
nucléaire à savoir les armes les
vecteurs et les porteurs la marge de
manœuvre restante vous semble-t-elle
suffisante pour amorcer le saut
capacitaire promis merci la parole est à
Delphine ingaman
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre avec l'évolution récente de la
situation internationale marquée
notamment par l'arrivée de la guerre de
haute intensité sur le continent
européen la future loi de programmation
militaire prévoit la mise en oeuvre de
mesures pour impulser un changement de
paradigme mais faciliter la transition
vers l'économie de guerre nos
industriels de labellité sont partis
prenant de ces enjeux et contribueront
activement à ce défi du passage à
l'économie de guerre du salut ici la
méthode du ministre des armées qui est
dans la préparation de la LPM avait
installé plusieurs groupes de travail
transpartisans et transdisciplinaires
dont un consacré à ce sujet fruits des
réflexions de ce groupe rassemblant
industriel DGA et parlementaire de tout
bord un chapitre de la LPM est consacré
aux dispositions relatives à l'économie
de guerre ma question portera sur le
régime de gradation des réquisitions
militaires présentées dans l'article 23
de la LPM pouvez-vous monsieur le
ministre apporter des précisions sur ces
mesures normatives destinées à nos
industriels de la défense merci la
parole est à Jean-Philippe Hardouin
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre merci pour vos propos qui
montrent la volonté du gouvernement de
continuer à redonner à nos armées les
moyens de mener leur multiples actions
si importantes dans un contexte de
grande tension internationales la future
loi de programmation militaire sera à la
fois ambitieuse et inédite elle traduira
un renforcement historique de notre
défense voulu par le Président de la
République c'est un véritable signal
envoyé à nos forces armées et à nos
partenaires pour le maintien durant de
la France à l'international et pour
notre souveraineté dans un récent
entretien la presse vous avez évoqué au
titre des urgences opérationnelles à
prendre en compte prioritairement notre
capacité en matière de drone et de lutte
antidrone vous citez notamment cette
menace en vue des Jeux olympiques de
2024 monsieur le ministre dans un
contexte à la fois de lutte contre le
terrorisme de guerre conventionnelle
quel budget dans cette loi de
programmation militaire sera consacrée
spécifiquement à la lutte antidrone et
d'autre part quels seront les priorités
d'investissement dans ce domaine tant en
termes de technologie que des formations
Ressources Humaines je vous remercie
merci la parole est à Muriel levreau
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre en raison de la nature
particulière des missions de nos armées
celles-ci sont exemples de certaines
mesures des accords de Paris néanmoins
au regard de la situation climatique et
écologique il est essentiel d'inclure
des objectifs ambitieux pour nos armées
en la matière concernant par exemple les
carburants comment envisagez-vous
d'anticiper la raréfaction des
ressources pétrolières et l'augmentation
des coûts et en d'autres termes
pouvez-vous nous détailler les
engagements qui seront pris pour réduire
l'empreinte carbone et enclencher une
véritable transition énergétique et
écologique de nos armées merci merci la
parole est à Christian Girard
merci le président merci Monsieur le
Ministre l'obsession du couple
franco-allemand en matière de défense
pose un certain nombre de problèmes car
là où les Allemands font du business
nous nous faisons du lyrisme en effet
alors que nous voulons nous avons voulu
renforcer la coopération avec
l'Allemagne avec le choix du HK416
notamment nous espérons que Berlin fasse
le choix de matériel français mais en
réalité ils se sont tournés vers les
Américains l'Europe Severin et autonome
n'est pas pour tout de suite de manière
générale les modèles d'armée française
et allemands sont très différents et les
bénéfices pour la France des programmes
scafé et mgcs sont à interroger nous
restons prisonniers de nos bons
sentiments quand la btid allemande elle
essaie de tirer le maximum d'avantages
commercial sur mgcs nous avons besoin de
charléger et rapide quand l'Allemagne
préfère des chars lourds plus lourds
aussi Monsieur le Ministre pourquoi
s'obstiner avec ces programmes Scaff et
mgcs merci
merci la parole est à Christophe Bex
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre
juste pour vous dire une audition du
premier magistrat de la Cour des comptes
se déroulera tout à l'heure mais
permettez-moi quand même de revenir sur
les conclusions de la vie rendu par le
Haut Conseil des finances publiques
concernant le projet de loi de
programmation militaire 2024 2030
l'impact de votre projet est à nouveau
jugé comme étant incertain un certain en
raison d'un écart existait entre les
besoins les créditifs le Haut Conseil
des finances identifiant en effet un
delta de 13,3 milliards d'euros ainsi
comment comptez-vous financer ces 13,3
milliards ces dépenses supplémentaires
prévues sont-elles bien prises en compte
dans la trajectoire de dépenses du
projet de loi de programmation des
finances publiques et comment
comptez-vous assurer une solidarité
interministérielle pour financer le
reste à couvrir lorsqu'on sait que ces
traditionnellement le budget des armées
qui fait l'objet de réduction de crédit
pour couvrir des dépenses
exceptionnelles je vous en remercie
merci la parole est à Lisa de métayer
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre alors que le Président de la
République entame aujourd'hui un voyage
d'État en Chine et à quelques jours la
présentation au Parlement la loi de
programmation militaire la question des
capacités françaises dans la zone à
d'autres Pacifique se pose donc la
France deuxième plus grande zone
économique exclusive et très présente
dans la dopacifique à travers ses
territoires
ultramarins mais c'est aussi le seul
pays de l'Union européenne qui est
présente dans cette zone stratégique où
se trouve 5 dédiés plus grands pays
commerçants mondiaux donc face au
durcissement de l'environnement
militaire et à la bascule stratégique
vers cet espace la France se doit être à
la hauteur du défi donc la mer est
devenue un espace de conflictualité je
prendrai comme exemple maîtrise des
fonds marins dont j'ai été coin porteur
au sein de cette commission une mission
est en formation en début d'année et la
Marine nationale est garant de nos
intérêts dans cette région et doit être
souveraine et dotée en conséquence et
vous l'avez rappelé dans vos propos
liminaires nos territoires ultramarins
sont plus vulnérables j'étais à vos
côtés à Lorient pour la mise à l'eau de
la première frégate de nouvelle
génération de défense et d'intervention
pépites technologies issue notre BITD et
de notre recherche alors monsieur le
ministre le nombre de frégates prévus
dans la prochaine loi de programmation
militaire et les sloguement de leur
livraison nous permettront-ils d'y
défendre adéquatement nos intérêts dans
un territoire alors que la compétition
sur place sa croissance cette LPM
historique ne pourrait-elle pas prévoir
la commande supplémentaire de FDI dans
cette zone stratégique du monde je vous
remercie la parole est à Emmanuel
Fernandes
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre les besoins programmés pour les
infrastructures teignes 16 milliards
dans cette nouvelle LPM mais pouvez-vous
nous apporter des précisions sur les
éléments qui ont permis de fixer cet
objectif singulièrement pour ce qui a
des montants que vous prévoyez
d'affecter au logement des militaires
nous abordons ici régulièrement cette
question du logement notamment l'état
souvent vétust du parc domanial qui
représente 27% du parc global or près
des deux tiers des logements de maniaux
ont plus de 60 ans et se trouve trop
souvent dans un état très dégradé voir
frisant l'insalubrité outre l'aspect
qualitatif des logements il y a
également le quantitatif le problème de
l'offre en logement par rapport à la
demande on sait que sur 10 demandes
seules 6 logements sont attribués alors
dans quelle mesure considérez-vous que
l'augmentation des besoins programmés
permettra de combler ses besoins en
logement à l'horizon 2030 et en quelle
proportion l'augmentation prévue des
besoins programmés pour le poste
logement est-elle destinée à la
rénovation notamment thermique du parc
de Manial à la construction de nouveau
log ements ou à la multiplication de
conventions signées avec des
propriétaires tiers qui viendraient
alimenter le portail informatique atrium
en offre de logement je vous remercie
merci la parole est à Martine Étienne
elle est pas là la parole est à Benoît
Borda
monsieur le ministre vous avez réaffirmé
votre volonté d'augmenter les effectifs
de la réserve opérationnelle afin de les
porter à 100.000 hommes et femmes vous
avez d'ailleurs organisé plusieurs
groupes de travail afin de lever les
freins au recrutement de nouveaux
réservistes et répondre à cet objectif
ambitieux ce recrutement important
engendrera la mise à disposition de
moyens humains d'encadrement mais
également du matériel supplémentaire
ainsi pourriez-vous nous indiquer
monsieur le ministre la répartition
envisagée pour ses 100.000 hommes et
femmes dans les différentes composantes
de la réserve opérationnelle ainsi que
les moyens mis en œuvre pour les
intégrer je vous remercie
merci la parole est à Jean-Marie Fivet
merci Monsieur brillant monsieur le
ministre lors de la Monna nature
précédente en 2021 j'ai rédigé que ma
collègue Isabelle Santiago un rapport
d'information portant sur la transition
écologique du ministère des armées
la prise en compte de la transition
écologique mais aussi énergétique du
ministère et par voie de dérivée de nos
armées est aujourd'hui un élément
essentiel à prendre en compte dans notre
stratégie de défense
j'ai jamais françaises font partie des
quelques armées autour du globe cette
engagée en cette logique et ce dès 2007
avec le premier plan d'action
environnemental du ministère des armées
depuis et malgré les difficultés
évidentes liées aux activités de nos
armées le ministère n'a eu de cesse
devrait en faveur d'une défense
nationale durable plus récemment encore
dans le cadre du projet de loi de
finances 2023 LPM année 5 le ministère
s'engageait au travers de diverses
mesures dans la conduite des transitions
écologiques et énergétiques ainsi
Monsieur le Ministre pourriez-vous
m'indiquer quelle mesure sont prévues
dans le futur LPM en faveur et
transition écologique et énergétique de
nos armées je vous remercie merci il
reste trois questions la parole est à
Frédéric Mathieu
oui monsieur le ministre la question des
exportations d'armement peut pas être
traitée à la légère un petit peu comme
vous l'avez fait vous me pardonnerez si
je suis un peu sévère tout à l'heure
c'est pas pour ou contre les exports
c'est comment on exporte et vers où et
avec quel comment dire avec quel notion
de l'intérêt général que nous avons en
tête en ce qui concerne les marchands
l'intérêt général on va le mettre de
côté la dernière fois que nous les avons
eu en audition en ce qui concerne un
certain nombre d'exportations notamment
vers des pays dictatoriaux des grandes
démocraties théocratiques comme par
exemple les Émirats arabes ou l'Arabie
Saoudite ils disent nous on est là pour
vendre on fait du business c'est leur
intérêt particulier ils ont bien raison
l'intérêt général il est pris en compte
ou il est pris en compte dans le
Parlement il est pris en compte chacun
au gouvernement chacun ce qu'il concerne
ce qu'on dit c'est qu'on a suffisamment
eu de ministre des armées qui se
comportaient comme des représentants de
commerce et que la sécurité de nos
ressortissants ou qu'il soit dans le
monde ou qu'il soit dans le monde est un
intérêt essentiel à défendre et la
prolifération d'armes menace cet intérêt
essentiel vous avez encore râpé tout à
l'heure la situation une politique dans
laquelle on est prenons les choses au
sérieux disquons-en sérieusement et puis
allons-y merci merci la parole est à
Estelle Youssoupha merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Ministre pour
revenir sur la question de Mayotte et
les langues ultramarins dans la loi de
programmation militaire les enjeux
stratégiques dans la zone est de leçon
indien ou la menace et les tensions sont
réelles je tiens à rappeler que le 17
février dernier les Marines
sud-africaine chinoises et russes ont
mené des exercices militaires à quelques
centaines de kilomètres de nos côtes
mahoraises et à quelques centaines de
kilomètres des champs gaziers de Total
dans le canal du Mozambique je souligne
ici les risques d'instrumentalisation
des flux migratoires définies par l'OTAN
comme menace hybride et que nous
observons à Mayotte avec la
déstabilisation causée par l'immigration
comorienne monsieur le ministre Mayotte
aura-t-elle un patrouilleur outremer
affecté à temps plein pour protéger
notre frontière avez-vous décidé de la
construction de la base navale en eau
profonde à Mayotte je vous remercie
merci la parole est à Natalia pousse
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre les menaces hyper vélos de type
balistique ou plus encore planeur
hypersonique représente un défi pour les
systèmes de défense actuels y compris
les plus sophistiqués à ce titre je me
félicite que la Commission européenne
réévalue sa position concernant le
projet
IDEF et envisage de soutenir un second
projet d'intercepteurs d'armes
hypersonique cette fois confiée à MDA
qui reste le missilier européen par
excellence la France poursuit
l'évolution du sommepeté par le standard
océan qui présente une capacité initiale
d'interception de cible hypersonique en
phase terminale c'est évolutions
contribuent au renforcement d'ailleurs
de la défense collective le santé Mamba
étant intégré au système
access de l'OTAN l'étape suivante serait
l'évolution vers un standard OC2 qui
consisterait à mondialiser toutes les
composantes du somme TNG éventuellement
par la jonction d'un radar type UHF qui
pourrait nous prémunir de menaces venant
du sud c'est d'ailleurs ce que nous
avons recomm Andé dans notre rapport
avec Jean-Louis Herriot sur la défense
solaire en France et en Europe donc 5
millions d'euros sont prévus dans cette
nouvelle LPM pour la défense surface r
des évolutions vers le standard OC2
sont-elles prévues dans ces 5 milliards
pour faire face à ces nouvelles menaces
concernant le les évolutions du mandat
merci Monsieur le Ministre oui je vais
alors si vous en êtes d'accord j'essaie
de vraiment répondre à tout le monde
peut-être que parfois j'accélérais et
évidemment je suis à votre disposition
par ailleurs ou mon cabinet pour faire
des compléments ou des rendez-vous enfin
voilà l'audition enfin cette deuxième
édition est un point de départ c'est pas
pour moi la terminaison de notre affaire
je reprends peut-être dans l'ordre
inverse par lequel elles sont arrivées
même posé avant santé NG c'est un
programme absolument clé il y a des
dimensions très techniques dans votre
question que d'ailleurs Thalès nous a
posé par ailleurs donc on aura
l'occasion de leur répondre et je pense
que vous aurez à connaître une audition
du DGA j'imagine à huis clos donc ça
vous permettra évidemment de de lui
poser ces questions là dans la copie
telle que je vous la présente on est sur
une cible à 8 l'idée c'est de pouvoir
porter la cible à 12 ensuite j'ai aussi
de bons espoirs sur l'exportation faut
reconnaître que le sante non NG c'est à
dire l'actuel qui a été promis à
l'Ukraine montre aussi quand même
l'attente vis-à-vis de de ce type de
système je le redis pour l'ensemble des
comm parlementaires c'est l'équivalent
de la classe des patriotes américains
donc on est vraiment dans le haut du
spectre donc ça je vous rassure les
choses sont dans la dans la copie ce
qu'il faut c'est tenir aussi des délais
de livraison assez rapidement madame
Youssoupha alors sur les trois aspects
de votre question qui nous permet aussi
quand même de parler de cette zone Indo
qui est quand même bien particulier pour
le territoire de Mayotte puisque si que
situation connue évidemment liée aux
gros défi que pose évidemment les sujets
migratoires mais vous l'avez dit je vous
en remercie les sujets liés aux
terrorisme au Mozambique dont on parle
trop peu malheureusement et qui sont un
enjeu clé peut-être deux choses que je
n'ai jamais dit publiquement enfin une
annonce déjà je me rendrai au Comores en
tant que mini des armes et prochainement
pour avoir une discussion de sécurité
avec le président azali parce que pour
le coup je pense que c'est très
responsabilité aussi que de que de
traiter les sujets de souveraineté et
compris maritime entre les eaux
françaises et les eaux comoriennes à me
rendre sur place assez rapidement et
puis aussi vous dire qu'on actuellement
un instrument de coopération avec le
Mozambique pour les aider à lutter
contre le terrorisme genre l'occasion
d'y revenir mais en tout cas au delà du
capacité il y a ce volet là sur le
capacités pour le coup on aura
l'occasion de décliner la la comment
dire la copie outre-mer je vous le
disais dans un autre cas sachez que oui
un renforcement global des phase œil et
deux affectations plus permanente de
moyens a Mayotte qui reste des moyens
phase œil mais qui seront dédiés à
Mayotte pour le faire vite et je
rajouterai les drones à mon avis sont
une des grandes un des grands monsieur
moraux pardonnez-moi vous mon conseiller
vous cache la question des drones est
absolument clé puisque certes il faut du
patrouilleur maritime la question des
Falcon évidemment est clé parce que on a
vu dans le passé que ça a des effets
dissuasifs importants sur les
différentes filières de migration mais
il est clair que la question des drones
est absolument clé pour l'avenir on aura
besoin d'y revenir en tout cas mettez
engagé auprès de vous et auprès des élus
de Mayotte de là où je viens de mes
présentes fonctions en plus pour pour
vous dire que oui il y avait bien une
déclinaison mahoraise à la loi de
programmation militaire base navale ça
me rajeunit de quelques mois cette
affaire nous ne sommes pas chez nous au
sens état du terme puisque comme vous le
savez une grande partie du foncier c'est
le conseil départemental qui en a la
comment dire la compétence donc ça
renvoie aussi à des discussions avec les
autorités locales dont j'imagine que le
ministre de l'intérieur des Outre-mer
doit avoir par ailleurs en ce moment en
tout cas on aura l'occasion de dire
monsieur Mathieu merci pour la précision
sur les exportations d'armes et non vous
n'êtes pas dur
défendez vos convictions à la matière
donc ça je vous reprocherai jamais alors
après je pense qu'il faut aller jusqu'au
bout Emirats arabes unis que vous
considérez qu'il faut qu'on ferme la
base aérienne 104 et qu'on doit dénoncer
nos accords de défense moi je considère
que pour l'intérêt général du pays
ce point d'appui est fondamental pour
notre sécurité on revient la dopacifique
comme Djibouti pour d'autres raisons non
mais je le dis et je le pense vraiment
on dirait l'autre donc on pourra revenir
évidemment sur la question des
exportations d'armes mais elle participe
malgré tout à l'équilibre du modèle ça
je pense que c'est en tout cas le modèle
il a été construit comme ça ça c'est
factuel il repose là dessus donc ou
alors c'est donc une relation différente
à l'argent du contribuable parce que ça
veut dire qu'il faudra encore plus de
dépenses publiques militaire mais si la
France insoumise plus d'argent encore
pour les armées je crois que c'est
intéressant de le savoir et qui permet
de interroger le modèle non mais je dis
sans provocation mais je pense que c'est
utile quand même de faut que tout le
monde réexplique le modèle pour mieux
dire peut-être que vous n'êtes pas
d'accord avec mais je pense que c'est
important de le réexpliquer sinon plus
personne ne comprend rien et je pense
que notre devoir collectif c'est
permettre à nos concitoyens de voir
comment cette affaire est organisée sur
les questions liées la transition
écologique donc je crois que le député
Fiévé me poser la question je crois
aussi que Madame la écoutez vous avez
également posé cette question je crois
qu'il y a plusieurs volets bon un déjà
des efforts ont été faits faut rendre
hommage aux armées parce que c'est de la
conduite quotidienne on a diminue moitié
les consommations de fuel faut dire
qu'on partait de loin
évidemment on a diminué de
22%, je vous l'avais déjà dit un certain
nombre de dépenses énergétiques il est
clair que tout rénovation des infras
doit s'accompagner d'un plan de sobriété
énergétique sur sur nos bases et sur nos
régiments donc là je pense que les
effets sont spectaculaires dans la
programmation militaire à venir parce
que tout simplement on va vraiment
changer la manière dont nos bâtiments
sont structurés si on va au-delà je
pense qu'on a un enjeu aussi sur les
énergies renouvelables parce que parfois
nous sommes un grand propriétaire de
foncier donc en matière solaire je pense
qu'on doit pouvoir faire mieux notamment
sur nos bases aériennes donc des
réflexions sont en cours je pense quand
on parle d'écologie il faut aussi ne pas
oublier que les emprises militaires sont
souvent de grosses réserves en matière
de biodivers et que là pour le coup il y
a des choses intéressantes à y faire
parce que comme des zones interdites par
définition on peut y protéger un certain
nombre d'espèces donc là je pense aussi
qu'il y a un point important et sur la
question aussi de la ressource en nous
moi j'ai passé des instructions sur la
sobriété en matière de ressources
naturelles haut puisque là aussi parfois
on a eu quand même des usages dans le
passé qui n'étaient pas que on aura
l'occasion de revenir dans la discussion
en tout cas les armées se sont emparées
de de cet enjeu et là aussi on pourra
peut-être vous communiquer par ailleurs
des informations plus précises et
exactes y compris de manière
territoriale sur ce qui peut être mené
ici ou là réserve opérationnel alors là
aussi monsieur député Bordas pour le
coup il y a aussi une dimension pas que
un terrar armée toutes les armées sont
concernées partant du principe que le
ratio concerne tout le monde c'est donc
d'avoir mettre terre qui sera le plus
saillant le plus évident et donc
challenge est le plus fort j'ai demandé
aussi à ce qu'on nous fasse des
projections par département par
délégation militaire départementale ce
sont des cibles après ne vous accrochez
pas assez cibles parce que dans un
département on aurait moins et dans un
appartement on aurait trop ça n'aurait
connaissances en tout cas je pense que
c'est un des moyens aussi de réussir
territorialiser cette affaire est un des
moyens de responsabiliser chaque DMD
chaque chef de corps chaque officier
général de défense ou de préfet maritime
en tout cas je crois que là il y a un
enjeu et j'aurai l'occasion aussi de
vous communiquer ces chiffres parce
qu'ils seront presque il n'est pas
encore le cas au moment où je vous parle
monsieur le député je crois Fernandez
sur les questions de logement
pardonnez-moi bon là il est clair que on
a plusieurs enjeux alors ils écrivent
différemment en fonction qu'il soit deux
maniaux dans les lignes d'infras telles
que je voulais indiquer tout à l'heure
l'idée c'est que on était à 8000
logements on souhaite passer à 15000
logements via le contrat dans son déjà
parlé en commission le contrat c'est
gelec c'est bien ça c'est génial
pardonnez moi
donc ça c'est un enjeu là où je pense
qu'on a une marge de progression
importante c'est surtout ce qui est
conventionné hors de manière l'idée avec
les collectivités locales et donc
surtout bailleur et là je pense qu'on a
on a un enjeu enfin Neymar je
progression qui me semble évidente et
certaine mais là aussi à l'occasion d'y
revenir
ultérieurement en tout cas c'est un
sujet qui est qui est important le
nombre de frégates
pour pour Lorient
non je pense que c'est la bonne cible
pour nos armées après on y reviendra sur
les marches parce que c'est j'insiste un
quelle armée on veut enfin alex est
parti je vais répondre après mais même
si les parties mais je je veux dire on
peut on peut mettre 1000 milliards de
dépenses militaires non on peut vouloir
faire les États-Unis d'Amérique même le
général de Gaulle n'a jamais voulu faire
ça non mais je le dis sans provocation
aucune c'est que je pense qu'il faut
aussi définir une cible qui soit
soutenable soutenable après en équipage
soutenable en entretien en MCO
soutenable en mission je pense qu'on en
aura jamais assez si on en va là et que
le devoir de nous autres politique c'est
de trouver le bon équilibre entre ce qui
est utile
en fonction des différentes menaces et
évidemment les marins et moi le premier
on aimerait en faire plus néanmoins vous
pourriez peut-être poser la question
différemment est-ce que Lorient peut
produire plus de frégate pour parler
plutôt de l'impact industriel oui alors
viens nous affaires d'export voilà pour
le coup il y a quand même des
discussions importantes pas que sur les
frégates sur les sous-m sur peine sur
l'égoïne sur bref il y a toute une gamme
de naval Group qui à mon avis au regard
des enjeux de sécurité maritimes que je
décrivais succinctement tout à l'heure à
mon avis sont de beaux enjeux et là pour
le coup pour rassurer les députés de la
France insoumise en plus avec des vrais
démocraties dans le bassin méditerranéen
je pense que les efforts que les Grecs
sont en train de faire sur leur marine
c'est intéressant Chypre séparé donc là
il y a des enjeux sur lequel évidemment
il faudra aussi qu'on revienne qui à mon
avis intéressant aussi pour les sujets
de sécurité collective sur le Haut
Conseil des finances publiques monsieur
le député alors merci d'y revenir ça me
permet de de leur répondre à travers
vous bon les 13,2 milliards d'euros ne
sont pas incertain c'est ce que je
disais tout à l'heure sur les recettes
extra budgétaires elles sont documentées
elles sont chiffrées donc j'ai demandé à
ce qu'on voulait pas se passer comme ça
vous aurez le tableau avec les sommes
comme pour les reports de charges comme
pour les les marges les différentes
marges fonctionnelles c'est la force
aussi du ministère des armées d'avoir
ses propres ressources c'est une somme
petite sur les 413 milliards c'est 13
milliards mais c'est sûr que c'est un
modèle particulier et unique qu'on ne
retrouve pas dans les autres ministères
parce qu'ils n'ont pas forcément ce
système de recettes donc là c'est
soutenable la réalité monsieur député en
fait c'est toujours été le cas et j'ai
considéré que pour cette copie c'était
bien de montrer les deux chiffres 413 et
400 parce qu'en fait sur les périodes
précédentes il y avait déjà des
ressources extra budgétaires ce que
j'aimerais également pour mon cabinet
c'est qu'on donne au parlementaire les
ressources extra budgétaires des dix
dernières années comme ça ça va vous
montrer que c'est pas c'est pas du faux
argent et que c'est bel et bien de
parfois c'était plutôt des produits de
session parfois c'est le SSA donc vous
le verrez comment c'est fait mais c'est
pas au doigt mouillé quelque chose on se
dit tiens on essaiera de boucler plus
tard ça correspond véritablement à des
choses qui existent donc ça on va vous
donner tous les documents et si vous en
manque ou si vous souhaitez accéder à
des choses évidemment on vous les
donnera sur les questions liées je vous
en prie sur les questions liées aux
coopération avec l'Allemagne dont je ne
doute pas qu'on reviendra
dans les temps qui viendront
bon l'expression bon sentiment elle est
politique elle vous appartient monsieur
le député après la réalité c'est que
notre modèle d'armée fait
que on ne transigera pas avec des vrais
fondamentaux et de vrais lignes rouges
donc si je devais dire les choses le
Scaff à la fin ça ressemblera aussi à un
avion qui sera utile pour notre Armée de
l'Air dissuasion nucléaire comprise
voilà on peut pas dire plus clair ça
veut dire que ne pensez pas vous avez le
droit de le penser politiquement mais en
tout cas sincèrement entre nous ne
pensez pas que nous soyons naïfs en quoi
que ce soit et moi j'ai demandé à
l'armée de l'air lorsque j'ai confirmé
récemment la tranche 5 du Rafale de
commencer aussi à clairement dire
précisément parce que parfois la
faiblesse est chez nous monsieur le
député d'être trop flou sur ce que nous
attendons du futur avion c'est aussi
l'Armée de l'Air et de l'Espace parce
que aussi force à une stratégie parce
que des missions qui sont bien précises
de dire le Scaff il doit ressembler à ça
ça comprend la dissuasion ça compréhend
aussi la dimension aéronavale et ça
évidemment c'est à nous de le dire aux
partenaires allemands pas que
trop souvent les Espagnols ce qui n'est
pas élégant vis-à-vis de donc il faut le
il faut le rappeler et peut-être demain
d'autres partenaires je vais le redire
devant la prévention de la nation mais
il y aura un successeur rafale quoi
qu'il arrive et quoi qu'il arrive il
devra correspondre aux intérêts
souverains français après monsieur
député partager l'addition à plusieurs
dans le dans cette affaire à du bon
aussi pour le contribuable et c'est
aussi ce qui se passe et ça permet aussi
de garantir la soutenabilité des
programmes mais j'imagine qu'on y
reviendra d'ailleurs
si j'avais une inquiétude elle serait
plus sur le mgccès est-ce que sur le
Scaff parce que le Scaff la France est
chef de fil faut le redire aussi parce
que parfois on doute du Scaff alors que
c'est nous qui en sommes chef de fil et
d'assaut les premiers donc et c'est eux
qui tiennent aussi un peu le rythme de
cette affaire donc je peux avoir des
inquiétudes politiques
peut-être politicienne sur le SCAF
néanmoins sur le fond le Scaff c'est la
France qui est quand même donne la mgcs
c'est pas le cas donc ce que vous avez
dit sur le mgcs je ne refuse pas
complètement et je vois le programme
prendre du retard et ça m'inquiète je le
dis devant vous avec beaucoup d'humidité
je dis ceci rescave mgcs si vous me le
permettez y compris dans la suite de
notre travaux ensemble je pense que
c'est pas du tout les mêmes les mêmes
objets à la fin ni les mêmes enjeux ni
les mêmes conduites sur transition
écologique j'ai déjà répondu
Parlement madame Thomas donc merci de
d'y être revenu je pense que c'est très
très important et on aura l'occasion
d'en débattre ensemble sur comment il
faut faire bon l'inflation elle est
traitée je le redis parce que bon pour
tout je pourrais m'en moquer parce que
je ne suis communier des armées mais en
fait c'est le seul ministère dans lequel
l'inflation est traitée
et c'est ça que je trouve assez curieux
d'y revenir autant de fois je me permets
de vous le dire elle est traitée avec
des mesures de gestion et les traités de
l'argent nouveau quand vous avez pas
peine ou François Brown en général on
leur pose jamais autant la question de
l'impact de l'inflation sur le programme
des constructions hospitalières or pour
autant pardon mais le ministère de la
Santé n'a pas du tout les outils de
gestion d'inflation je devrais pas le
dire comme ça mais je le dis quand même
ça c'est en sincérité je veux dire s'il
y a bien un ministère qui a les moyens
de traiter l'inflation c'est celui-ci
donc je vous avais raison de me poser la
question mais une fois que je vous ai
répondu vous voyez ce que après je
pourrais encore le redocumenter
évidemment si vous le souhaitez même la
députés mais pour le coup c'est traité
c'est traité et les report de charge
pardon sont un bon outil
parce qu'en plus l'inflation je l'espère
après ça dépend de votre caractère si
vous êtes optimiste ou pessimiste sur
les prévisions d'inflation mais on se
dit aussi que cette inflation telle
qu'on la connaît ne durera pas et qu'à
un moment donné quand on aura cette
décroissance j'espère je fais aussi se
parier pour être honnête avec vous avec
humidité c'est de se dire qu'à un moment
donné on va retrouver aussi des marges
manœuvres et on sera content d'ailleurs
de s'acquitter de factures avec les
reports de charge au moment où les
facteurs macroéconomiques seront
meilleurs donc il y a un pari collectif
à faire mais si on compare aussi
l'égalises des années 60 et l'inflation
qu'il connaissaient jusqu'au choc 74 ça
sera on sera vous ne serez pas la
première législature et moi le premier
ministre a traité ce sujet en tout cas
depuis et d'ailleurs parce que ce sont
souvent les députés qu'ils l'ont voulu
et qui l'ont imposé au gouvernement dans
le passé faut être honnête il y a des
mesures pour traiter l'inflation et ça
c'est plutôt l'héritage de vos
prédécesseurs au Parlement qui l'ont
voulu donc je pense qu'on pourra là
aussi encore y revenir une nouvelle fois
enfin on a quand même les outils pour se
faire
alors bonne question sur diffusion
nucléaires et conventionnelles j'estime
que l'équilibre est le bon mais c'est
vrai que on n'a pas le temps de tout
détailler il est le bon même la
difficulté possible parce qu'on a un
modèle qui est original dans certains
puissances dotées les forces nucléaires
font leur vie complètement à part chez
nous notre modèle fait que les contrats
opérationnels liés la dissuasion sont
très imbriquées avec les contrats
conventionnels
les forces ADN stratégiques pour donner
un exemple très précis les rafales qui
sont employés pour les faces même des
missions qui parfois sont non nucléaires
donc en fait cette organisation là y
compris d'ailleurs pour nos notre marine
à ce mérite c'est que la dissuasion
nucléaire a toujours tiré l'ensemble
vers le haut parce qu'en fait ça
garantit des moyens qui peuvent aussi
être utilisés différemment donc ça pour
répondre à votre question les équilibres
sont les bons mais là aussi je pourrais
évidemment y revenir et répondre à vos
questions plus avant sur les drones
monsieur le député oh cool alors pour le
coup bon déjà la filière n'est pas que
militaire doit être dual parce que pour
beaucoup d'usages y compris en sécurité
civile pour les 10 pour les entreprises
enfin bref je pense que si on veut avoir
une filière souveraine là aussi il faut
qu'on soit capable d'accrocher toutes
les opportunités sur sur tous les côtés
donc ça c'est absolument clair je pense
que il faut pas revivre ce qui s'est
passé sur le Reaper et ça pour le coup
on remarque etc vous nous permettent de
le faire les sommes importantes que
j'indiquais tout à l'heure
vont nous permettre quand même de donner
de la visibilité aussi sur évidemment la
filière drone avec des entreprises qui
commencent à faire des choses
intéressantes y compris d'ailleurs les
PME dont nous parlions tout à l'heure
dans le premier échange il est clair que
vu le rôle des drones à l'avenir il nous
faut être complètement souvent
des drones les plus petits munitions
téléopérée jetable en quelque sorte au
drone qui sont au final des petits
avions qui coûtent plusieurs millions
d'euros pour ça je pense que je suis sur
l'ensemble de la gamme il faut qu'on
avance avec les 5 milliards d'euros je
suis honnête avec vous je souhaite aussi
qu'on fasse travailler un peu la
concurrence les entreprises qui font des
choses bien Airbus d'assaut etc mais je
pense que là sur l'ensemble du spectre
si on se sert correctement de l'argent
on y arrivera et d'ailleurs je pense
aussi qu'il faut qu'on ait un modèle
soutenable parce que vous allez pas
commencer à avoir des drones qui coûtent
tellement cher qu'on en aura de manière
échantillonnaire donc il faut qu'on soit
capable aussi de réfléchir aux modèles
économique de ces drones ça c'est un
point qui est évidemment clé Thémis
madame la députée Martin oui les crédits
pour Témis sont reconduits surtout des
crédits de ressources humaines parce
qu'en fait c'est une plateforme de
personnes qui s'occupe de ça il y a pas
de crédit d'investissement si vous
voulez en tant que tel donc c'est dans
la copie RH il faut qu'on aille plus
loin encore sur cette question dans les
années qui viendront pas que par Themis
mais aussi par la la grande
sensibilisation du commandement parce
que tennis à son rôle à jouer vous
l'avez rappelé je souscris ce que vous
avez dit après c'est une affaire de
commandement au quotidien encadrement
sous-oeuf encadrement officier grand
chef militaire et capacité à proposer au
ministre quand il le faut les sanctions
qui doivent être prononcées je pense que
là-dessus il faut être absolument calme
et clinique sanction et poursuites
pénale s'il le faut même en tout cas moi
je pense que c'est l'armée de la qui
protège la nation de ceci l’armée de la
République donc par définition elle doit
aussi véhiculer ses valeurs là beaucoup
de choses ont été faites je pense
vraiment qu'il y a culturellement des
bons en avant qui sont SPECT enfin j'ai
encore des signalements ici là de temps
en temps soit par le commandement soit
par la DSD et à chaque fois je demande
est-ce que des sanctions sont instruites
en tout cas là aussi je pourrais revenir
sur ce sujet s'il vous plaît et c'est
nul alors oui vous avez raison Madame la
député parler de nouvelles élans citoyen
et de capacité à travailler la
résilience de la nation et à projeter la
jeunesse moi j'en suis évidemment
complètement convaincu je suis militant
du SMU je considère en plus que tenter
quelque chose de nouveau qui prendrait
le meilleur de l'école et le meilleur
des armées enfin dans notre histoire ça
vaut le coup d'essayer et d'ailleurs au
fond je note que sur tous les bancs il y
a pas de refus mais non monsieur député
s'intoule vous-même d'ailleurs vous avez
proposé des choses pendant la campagne
présidentielle donc là aussi enfin sauf
à ce que soit de l'opposition pour se
poser on n'a pas tous la même approche
de ce que peut-être le SMU mais tout le
monde ressent qu'il y a de la place pour
un objet comme celui-ci me trompe en
disant ça ou pas je crois que non vous
avez déjà oublié vos programmes
électoraux de l'année dernière ce dont
je ne doute pas bon donc tout le monde
ressent qui a quelque chose à proposer à
la jeunesse tout le monde le ressent
tout le monde aussi ressent qui a besoin
de relever de nouveaux défis notamment
lui la transition écologique pour ne
citer que celui-ci donc tout le monde
tourne autour de quelque chose
honnêtement après je l'ai dit tout à
l'heure le programmation militaire c'est
fait pour le format des armées et je
pense que mettre le signe dans la
programmation militaire n'était pas une
bonne idée voilà et donc c'est pour cela
que il s'y retrouve pas et que je crois
que pour le coup ça permet aussi de
réserver à des vecteurs spécifiques la
question du SNU ce qui me permet aussi
de répondre à la question qui a été
posée par Monsieur ça tout d'ailleurs
que au fond ça permet aussi de
rebasculer peut-être en analyse
budgétaire pour les sujets qui
pourraient toucher au SMU et pas en
programmation c'est un impactera pas la
programmation sauf évidemment ce qui est
déjà prévu qui touche aux réserve
c'est-à-dire en clair c'est normal parce
que les réserves c'est le format des
armées voilà je pense que c'est aussi
une question de lisibilité démocratique
sur l'utilisation de l'argent du
contribuable les réserves n'ont pas de
raison que ce soit pas traité par la LPM
c'est le cas donc si un jour le essai
nuit doit comprendre une passerelle vers
les réserves le s&u à ses propres
instruments et les réserves évidemment
sont la programmation militaire
sur la 400m
notamment c'est un outil qui est
absolument formidable quand on voit les
capacités d'élongation et d'emports
c'est un énorme changement qui est pas
notre également pour notre présence en
Afrique parce que plus on est capable de
projeter vite lourd loin plus évidemment
ça change aussi la nécessité d'avoir des
forces prépositionnées pourquoi on avait
des forces prépositionnées aussi parce
que le temps de rejoindre par la
métropole ou de l'Hexagone était très
long enfin j'enfonce une porte ouverte
mais souvent là aussi j'étais frappé de
lire des choses sur le changement de
posture de la France sur les bases
africaines sans tirées aussi des
conclusions des sauts technologiques qui
étaient ceux-là nous on ne remet pas en
cause la cible à 50 la proposition que
je vous fais c'est au moins 35 dans dans
la copie du rapport annexé la tel que
elle vous est proposée moi j'ai une
discussion avec évidemment Airbus avec
le partenaire espagnol avec les
Britanniques avec les Allemands
sur l'export je pense que pour le coup
quand vous voyez la manœuvre remarquable
techniquement tactiquement j'entends je
précise sur l'évacuation en Afghanistan
sur le le tarmac de l'aéroport vous
n'aviez que des A400 m et que des pays à
400 mm c'est-à-dire qu'aujourd'hui c'est
l'avion qui permet à coup sûr de
réaliser ça donc moi je
l'Amicale bienveillante pression aussi
que je mets sur les industriels je reste
persuadé qu'il faut mettre le paquet sur
l'export à la 400m c'est un des moyens
aussi de finir le programme alors après
les discussions avec les différents les
différents en tout cas au moins 35 quand
je dis au moins 35 c'est vraiment au
moins 35 c'est à dire que en fonction
aussi de l'inflation on y revient ce que
ni pas que ça existe si on avait un
retournement des facteurs ça peut
permettre peut-être d'aller un peu plus
loin de 35 parce que les usages pour la
400 m pour le coup ils sont là ils
existent et ils sont évidemment
importants les bâtiments de surface
monsieur le député Bru et sous-marin
aussi parce qu'au fond on peut pas
déconnecter les deux bon je pense qu'on
aura l'occasion d'y revenir plus
longuement une autre fois mais peut-être
même d'ailleurs par armé parce qu'au
final on l'a peu fait faire la LPM
approche terre je crois que c'est le
député mercenaire dit qu'il en reparlera
une prochaine fois il y a des choses à
dire approche Armée de l'Air approche
marine donc là peut-être qu'on le refera
de manière plus plus profonde et surtout
ça me permet aussi de répondre au député
marlex
l'histoire le rideau ne tombe pas
brutalement en 2030 ça serait une
lecture scolaire de la LPM là pour le
coup quand on raisonne comme ça la cible
est à 2035 c'est une évidence enfin le
programmation militaire elle donne des
crédits de paiement et des cibles sur
cinq ans et des cibles sur 10 ans à
chaque fois
à chaque fois en tout cas une bonne loi
programmation militaire elle fait ça
c'est sûr avant j'étais plutôt pour
faire mes trucs et puis supprimer donc
par définition la reconduite était plus
simple là il est clair qu'il faut déjà
se poser la question c'est quoi le
format d'armée a terminaison les formats
d'armée a-t-il terminaison c'est 2035 et
donc sur les bateaux de surface
typiquement vous avez quelque chose avec
des points de passage à 2030 qui sont
ambitieux et la terminaison se fera
entre 30 et 35 mais c'est normal et
d'ailleurs pour des raisons aussi qui
tient ce qu'on disait tout à l'heure
aussi sur les capacités à produire de
naval group sur les capacités à l'export
etc
après j'ai plutôt fait un choix pour la
marine de tenir des délais court sur
tout ce qui est sous marinade
passer la classe Barracuda avec les
changements vers le Suffren parce qu'il
y a des enjeux d'un froid je le dis à
côté de votre voisin député de Toulon
c'est que au fond quand vous avez des
gros objets comme les sous-marins du
clarnataque ce sont pas typiquement les
mêmes infrastructures d'accueil les
mêmes quais les mêmes enjeux d'entretien
donc avoir trop longtemps
deux types de sous-marins nucléaire
d'attaque ensemble c'est pas de bonne
gestion enfin forcément il y a un tulage
c'est inévitable mais ne pas avoir un
tulage qui dure trop longtemps me semble
être une bonne chose ce que la
différence avec scorpion pas parce que
je préférerais les marins l'armée de
terre on la remette des Romains c'est
juste que par définition les
infrascorpions sont d'une autre unité
une autre taille une autre échelle que
pour que pour les sous-marins donc
parlant de cette digression mais il y a
aussi tout ça à regarder impact MCO dans
le rythme des changements impact un
frein tout ça évidemment était documenté
par les forces armées et je serai aussi
vous en faire la démonstration monsieur
le député saint Toul je langage auprès
vous donc je vous l'annonce il y aura
aucune fermeture d'aucun aucune
structure du service de santé des armées
en province j'ai mené un certain nombre
de réunions ces derniers temps j'ai pas
encore rendu public la feuille de route
je pense que les fermetures pour le coup
n'ont pas de sens par rapport au rôle
que le service de santé des armées donne
au territoire concerné
étant entendu en plus que parfois
évidemment le système sanitaire civile
n'est pas toujours en bonne forme pour
dire les choses pudiquement néanmoins
moi j'ai souhaité que désormais on aille
à une spécialisation de ces antennes
typiquement sur la blessure psychique on
a commencé avec Patricia mirales à
travailler là-dessus vous le savez il y
a beaucoup de besoins qui sont exprimés
par les armées évidemment vous avez déjà
et persi mais je pense que ce serait une
faute lourde typiquement de ne traiter
ce sujet là si loin des forces alors
reviens la dimension de proximité du SSA
et pour le coup les antennes en région
moi je souhaite qu'on puisse désormais
avoir le plot un peu général enfin
pardon parfois il est déjà plus tout à
fait général et donc faut pas raconter
d'histoires ou alors il est lié à une
mission spécifique bref par exemple et
la dissuasion parce que participent
clairement aussi de la permanence à la
mer de nos séné-le donc faut pas
détacher parfois certains antennes du
SSA de la mission pour laquelle on avait
imaginé l'antenne ça je suis en train
aussi des retravailler et puis pour
Marseille pour Lyon pour Metz pour
prendre ou bordeaux voilà pour prendre
ces exemples là moi je souhaite qu'on
aille vers une spécialisation et
peut-être aussi plus connecté avec ce
que font les Invalides la stimulation
les avait donc je suis pas en train de
vous parler des maisons à tous c'est
encore autre chose mais vraiment sur du
soin et qu'on soit capable de
spécialiser ça vous donne un peu
l'orientation qu'on était en train de
prendre donc aucune fermeture et en
revanche en faire des antennes qui
soient véritablement des des antennes
avec de la permanence de soins sur des
thématiques de spécialisation qui
correspondent aux besoins milliers du
terrain réserviste compris voilà
globalement un peu là où nous en sommes
sur le service de santé des armées et
c'est nul je vous ai répond u sur
monsieur le député Giletti
alors votre question était directe à la
fin je reviens pas par les quelques
digressions que vous avez faites dans le
chemin de l'escalier
sur est-ce que le socle d'activité est
suffisant oui parce que on en parle
assez peu et ça me permettra encore de
répondre aux députés Marex qui est parti
c'est le je pense que souvent
pour ne pas avoir trop s'ennuyé
politiquement avec la question des
rythmes des programmes la tentation est
comprimé le MCO l'activité des forces
et pour cause ça se voit pas peu
s'affranchit pas le mur du son quelques
commissaires à la défense spécialiste en
compte les forces armées elles s'en
rendent bien compte et au fond on se dit
bah voilà on va préférer réduire
l'entraînement on va préférer réduire le
nombre d'heures qu'un aviateur va par
exemple faire
manche de son rafale ou de son mirage le
nombre d'heures à la mer et puis comme
ça ça permet quand même d'avoir des de
manière un peu scolaire des programmes
qui s'arrêtent bien à la borne de la LPM
en mode vous avez vu on a tout fini
scorpion 2030 tout va bien bon parce
qu'il y a quand même des contraintes
budgétaires elle existe enfin je ou
alors c'est pour tout le monde il n'y a
que le budget de la défense qui compte
et vous êtes prêt à tous présenter des
mesures d'économie par ailleurs enfin ça
on verra en tout cas je vois que
ce serait une faute terrible par rapport
à nos armées que vous connaissez bien
armée d'emploi que de réduire
l'entraînement et l'activité des forces
donc peut-être que j'ai pas assez
précisé dans mon propos introductif
qu'on peut vous faire passer les
chiffres sur l'activité des forces va
augmenter ou se maintenir pour en
fonction des armées des unités ça dépend
un très très haut niveau d'engagement et
ça pour moi c'est clé et entre réduire
l'activité et et lisser le programme
scorpion sur deux années de plus mon
choix est fait même si politiquement
c'est sûrement plus facile de faire
l'inverse en tout cas je pense que pour
les armées c'est comme ça qu'il faut le
faire ça j'ai pas beaucoup de doutes sur
sur la manière de s'y prendre
cadencement des marches on y reviendra
bon de toute façon je veux dire une
chose j'ai bien compris ce matin que
pour certains j'ai lu aussi le Figaro ce
matin bon je vois bien que c'est un des
moyens de prendre politiquement la copie
le plus je ne reprochais pas au député
la chose faire de la politique la
dernière fois par chose aux autres
groupes politiques LR Ouarn de vouloir
en faire après ce que je vois c'est que
nous la terminaison dans nos engagements
c'est 69 milliards Madame Le Pen je
crois a été autour de 68 milliards
madame Pécresse était à moins bon donc
dès lors qu'on est tous d'accord sur la
date et la somme après le rythme est une
affaire de contrainte sachant que de
toute façon c'est nous qu'en avons
visité exécuter la plus grande des
parties depuis 2017 donc après la
question des marches moi je la regarde
hyper calmement et hyper cliniquement il
faut que ça corresponde à un besoin
militaire en face et aussi une capacité
à mettre en tension les industriels
voilà je vous réponds merde la plus la
plus neutre qui soit et la plus engagée
en tout cas parce que ce qui compte
c'est que ça augmente vraiment voilà
après tant d'années de diminution ce qui
compte c'est l'effet final recherché
c'est une augmentation et pas que pour
augmenter pas que pour dire qu'on a
augmenté mais aussi évidemment pour
créer des effets militaires réels en
cela j'ai répondu au début de tes marlex
aussi bon arbitrage négatif je le redis
les étalement font partie des
programmations
ou alors bon en tout cas moi j'assume
cela ensuite pour terminer Monsieur le
Député place ça comme on dirait dans les
unités ça c'est clé vous le verrez avec
le DGA je lui ai demandé et confier la
mission de créer ce qu'on appelle une
force d'acquisition réactive c'est à
dire en clair sur certains régiments
unités ou certaines oui unité
typiquement comme les forces spéciales
dont je parlais tout à l'heure une
capacité à surréagère parfois des objets
civils qui peuvent avoir un usage pour
eux à des fins militaires et être en
capacité de l'acheter on revient à un
autre chantier dont je peux parler
depuis le début de l'audition c'est
évidemment la déconcentration et la
simplification nécessaire des circuits
de décision au sein du ministère qui
évidemment un ministère pyramidal et
Jacobins ce qui est plutôt rassurant
pour une force armée mais qui parfois
sur certains mécaniques administratives
on peut déconcentrer des sommes d'argent
et des capacités d'achat pourvu que tout
ça se fasse en cohérence évidemment
c'est le boulot après la souche est
freeplan et les ta major des armées de
veiller à ce que les choses il a déjà
est-ce que les choses qui soient faites
soient faites en cohérence de manière
globale en tout cas c'est prévu dans la
copie et sur l'accès financier de la
j'ai déjà un peu répondu tout à
l'heure mais de fait vous avez raison
d'y revenir voilà mesdames messieurs les
députés ce que j'ai essayé de vous dire
en peu de temps en m'excusant de ne pas
avoir été complet par définition sur un
exercice aussi fort j'ai oublié quelque
chose
pardonnez-moi chant normatif de LPM
économie de guerre merci mesdames les
députés de me rappeler à l'ordre oui
deux mesures simples il y en a plusieurs
de manière simple
en situation dégradée être capacité de
faire au moins de choses réquisitionner
y compris les stocks qui permet tout
simplement l'industrie de défense de le
faire dans un champ très orgue très
organisé on est vraiment dans des
mécanismes de protection à défense
nationale on fera pas ça n'importe
comment et le deuxième outil droite
priorisé donc là vous avez une
entreprise qui est en train de fabriquer
quelque chose vous dites attendez on
vous a acheté des choses c'est bien que
vous ayez des clients l'export mais vous
comprendrez que regarde la situation
sécuritaire dans lequel la France est
engagée on vous commande de prioriser la
commande française par rapport à une
autre commande ou une commande civile
française voilà ce qui permet de passer
en priorité devant les autres si je
devais les résumer d'un mot voilà les
deux les deux propositions qui sont
faites mais je pourrais vous donner le
détail tel qu'il est présenté dans le
dans le projet de loi merci monsieur le
ministre d'avoir relevé brièvement le
défi de répondre à l'ensemble de ces 34
questions l'espace de d'une audition mes
chers collègues prochaine à 15 heures en
salle des commissions des finances de
Pierre Moscovici premier président de la
Cour des comptes bon appétit à tous